bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur publ Sénat le texte sur la
sécurisation de l'emploi a donc été voté
par les sénateurs dans la nuit de samedi
à dimanche le texte a été adopté par 172
voix contre 24 après un débat houleux il
faut dire que le gouvernement a eu
recours au vote bloqué pour accélérer
les débats ce qui a suscité la colère
des sénateurs communistes ils ont retiré
tous leurs amendements avant de quitter
l'hémicycle retour donc ce matin sur
cette séance agitée bonne matinée à
tous nous arrivons à la section 2 du
texte en discussion l'article 11 est en
vote réservé sur l'article 12 j'ai une
demande de parole de Madame Goulet vous
y renoncez merci chers collègues nous
arrivons à l'amendement 619 de Monsieur
deessar sur l'article
12 619 619 c'est une c'est un
suppression
supprimer cet article vous comprenez ce
que j'en pense et sans doute s'il n'y
avait pas eu le vote bloqué mes
collègues socialistes se sera abstenu
donc on l'aurait supprimé enfin je ne
sais pas qu aur été le sort de cet
article les accords de maintien dans
l'emploi porte un grave préjudice aux
salariés qui sont soumis d'une part il
renverse la arch des normes en
permettant qu'un accord d'entreprise
puisse modifier en profondeur le contrat
de travail d'autre part le fait
d'appliquer une procédure de
licenciement individuel pour motif
économique pour plusieurs salariés est
contraire à la directive européenne
9859 ce du 20 juillet 98 qui prévoit une
procédure de licenciement
collectif merci Monsieur de cessard
le 602 monsieur de cessar c'est le
suivant ah oui il sont séparés donc je
devais demander l'avis
d'abord évidemment cet article constitue
un des socles de l'accord avis de
favorable monsieur le ministre même avis
merci Monsieur le Ministre vote réservé
sur le 602 monsieur le cessa à l'article
le diagnostic le diagnostic de grav
difficultés économique conjoncturell est
la condition sinequonon à l'instauration
d'un accord de maintien dans l'emploi on
en comprend aisément la raison les
sacrifices demandés au salariés tel que
la modification de la durée du travail
ou de la rémunération ne serait consenti
si l'entreprise n'était pas en grande
difficulté économique pour pourtant les
auteurs de ce texte considérer que les
représentants des salariés n'ont pas
leurs mot à dire sur la réalité du
diagnostic seul l'employeur seraithilité
à certifier l'existence d'une difficulté
économique drôle de conception de la
démocratie sociale pourtant si souvent
invoqué lors des débats autour de cette
loi le texte affirme en effet que le
diagnostic des difficultés économiques
doit être analysé avec les syndicats des
salariés or une simple analyse ne
signifie pas un accord le diagnostic
doit en effet être partagé par les
syndicats pour qu'un réel consensus
puisse s'établir qu'un réel dialogue
puisse' instaurer et que l'accord ne
soit pas le résultat d'une volonté
unilatérale de l'employeur l'existence
de graves difficultés économique
conjoncturelle de l'entreprise est un
élément essentiel sur lequel tous les
débats doivent être concentr concentrés
l'employeur ne doit pas pouvoir invoquer
ce motif à la légère ce motif ne doit
pas être un prétexte pour modifier en
profondeur les conditions de travail des
salariés voire pour les licenciés ces
conditions économiques mettant en
difficulté l'entreprise doivent être
également constatées et admises par les
les organisations syndicales
représentant les salariés afin de donner
une véritable légitimité à ces accords
de maintien dans l'emploi merci chers
collègues l'avis de la commission sur
cet amendement 602
oui merci madame la
Présidente mes chers collègues c'est un
débat sémantique est-ce que la situation
la conjoncture doit être être analyser
partager je crois que ce qui compte et
c'est l'esprit de l'accord c'est que
l'analyse de la conjoncture fasse
consensus entre les partenaires sociaux
et le chef d'entreprise et c'est ça qui
convient de retenir c'est la raison pour
laquelle le terme choisi et retenu par
les partenaires sociaux analyser me
convient je vous propose donc un avis
défavorable merci monsieur le ministre
sur cet
amendement oui même avis qui ce terme
d'ailleurs a donné lieu un débat
juridique devant le Conseil d'État qui
nous a proposé de retenir le terme de
analyser euh dans le terme partager il y
aurait une sorte de d'identité absolue
de vue entre le point de vue syndical et
le point de vue patronal je pense pas
que on soit non plus au pays des
bisonours comme disait quelqu'un et donc
il peut y avoir une analyse qui fasse
apparaître des points de vue différents
mais qui sont susceptibles d'être prises
en compte dans leurs
différences merci monsieur le ministre
nous en arrivons à l'amendement 603
toujours à l'article 12 monsieur de
cessar respecter l'impératif de
démocratie sociale dans lequel s'inscrit
ce projet de loi je propose au nom du
groupe écologiste un amendement visant à
améliorer l'information dont disposent
les organisations syndicales dans le
cadre des accords de maintien dans
l'emploi pour qu'un dialogue social
constructif et égalitaire puisse être
mené les accords de maintien dans
l'emploi sont conditionnés par
l'existence de graves difficultés
économiques conjoncturelles dans
l'entreprise il est il est alors
important que l'ensemble des
informations permettant d'en établir le
diagnostic soit transmise par
l'employeur au syndicat ces derniers qui
seront les signataires de l'accord
doivent disposer des éléments suffisants
pour juger non seulement de la
pertinence de l'accord mais aussi de
modalité de sa mise en œuvre il est
légitimement impensable pour les
organisations syndicales de signer un
accord dont il ne connaîtrait même pas
le ltive il convient alors que l'absence
de transmission par l'employeur des
informations permettant d'établir le
bien des difficultés économiques rend
cet accord caduc c'est une exigence de
transparence c'est le sens de cet
amendement merci chers collègues l'avis
de la commission sur l'amendement 603
monsieur le
rapporteur merci madame la Présidente
mes chers collègues notre collègue nous
propose un amendement qui annulerait
l'accord de maintien dans l'emploi si
d'aventure l'employeur ne transmettait
pas toutes les informations nécessaires
alors le caractère automatique de la
nulité de l'accord en cas de
transmission incomplète d'information me
paraît vraiment disproportionné le
moindre oubli aurait des conséquences
énormes et l'amendement est d'une
sévérité trop importante je rappelle par
ailleurs pour tenter de rassurer notre
collègue que les accords de maintien
dans l'emploi devront comporter une
clause pénale qui par nature et
protectrice des droits des salariés
c'est donc un avis
défavorable merci Monsieur le Ministre
votre
avis merci Monsieur le Ministre vote
réservé je suis saisie de deux
amendements faisant l'objet d'une
discussion
commune le l'amendement 507 est présenté
par Madame Goulet oui madame le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues dans le cadre de la mise en
œuvre des accords de maintien de
l'emploi le projet de loi prévoit que le
comité d' entreprise peut mandater un
expert comptable pour accompagner les
organisations syndicales dans l'analyse
du diagnostic et la négociation dans les
conditions prévues par l'article L
2325-35 du Code du travail le présent
amendement a pour objet de prévoire la
possibilité pour le comité d'entreprise
de mandater non seulement un expert
comptable mais aussi un avocat pour
assister les organisations syndicales
dans la phase de négociation des accords
de maintien de l'emploi l'élaboration
d'actes juridiques tels que les accords
collec mettre en œuvre des compétences
qui sont celles des avocats des
professionnels pas seulement des gens du
chiffre mais aussi des gens du droit
c'est pourquoi nous proposons que
s'agissant de l'assistance des
organisations syndicales dans la phase
de négociation qui précède l'élaboration
d'un accord collectif le comité
d'entreprise puisse mandater un avocat
en plus d'un expert comptable les deux
sont parfaitement complémentaires les
honoraires des professionnels ainsi
mandatés seraient à la charge de
l'entreprise merci Madame Goulet
le 548 rectifié présenté par Madame
Laborde euh notre amendement étant
identique à celui que vient de défendre
notre collègue Nathalie Goulet j'estime
que je n'ai rien à ajouter merci chers
collègues euh
là
cel merci je vais demander l'avis de la
commission sur ces deux amendements
identiques merci madame la Présidente on
peut prend on peut comprendre l'intérêt
de ces deux propositions totalement
convergentes qui visent à mobiliser les
compétences d'un avocat pour assister
les organisations syndicales j'ai
d'ailleurs reçu au titre de la
commission les représentants des des
avocats nous rappelant qu'ils étaient
susceptibles d'apporter leurs services
aux partenaires sociaux rien n'interdit
du reste aujourd'hui à un comité
d'entreprise de recourir au service d'un
avocat qu'il peut payer sur son propre
budget par ailleurs les organisation
syndicale aujourd'hui bénéficie de
services juridiqu dans leurs unions
locales sur ce point je souhaiterais
obtenir l'avis du
gouvernement avant que nous puissions
effectivement prendre une
décision merci Monsieur le le
rapporteurur ministre monsieur le
ministre oui oui madame la Présidente ne
m'avait pas échappé que les avocats
s'intéressaient à ce sujet j'ai même cru
voir quelques articles dans les journaux
sur ce point je voudrais les rassurer
vous rassurer mais les rassurer eux
aussi euh d'abord puisqueil y a quelques
éléments sur les experts l'expert sera
rémunéré par l'employeur ça c'est prévu
dans le texte de Laan et donc dans le
texte du projet de loi il est évidemment
possible pour les organisations
syndicales d'être accompagné par un
avocat évidemment on voit pas comment on
pourrait interdire qu'il en soit ainsi
c'est évidemment possible c'estibé qu'
est largement ouverte simplement Laan
dans ce CASL n'a pas prévu la
rémunération par l'employeur ça fait
peut-être aussi partie de l'équilibre
global ils ont prévu la rémunération
globale de de l'expert par l'employeur
mais pas celui de l'avocat et donc ce
sont les organisations syndicales qui
auront à supporter sur ce point la
rémunération des des avocats mais
certains j'avais vu quelques titres du
genre les avocats interdits dans
l'entreprise enfin dans
évidemment non leur place est dans
l'entreprise aussi que ce soit au côté
des salariés que ce soit au côté de la
direction de l'entreprise c'est c'est
c'est là qu'ils apportent leurs
connaissances et leur
savoir-faire merci Monsieur le Ministre
euh vote réservé sur ces deux
amendements nous arrivons à l'article 12
j'ai un amendement 624 monsieur de
cessar
oui madame la Présidente
dans le texte il est dit qu'un arrêt
fort proportionnel à celui des salariés
sera demandé aux mandataires sociaux et
aux actionnaires s'il n'y avait pas ce
cadre morose dans enfin si nous n'étions
pas dans cette atmosphère morose de
débat je
ferais en effet un effort proportionnel
à celui des salariés sera demandé au
mandataires sociaux et aux actionnaires
voir ah ah ah ah hein alors c'est quoi
un effort proportionnel pour un patron
c'est un petit pourcentage c'est en
valeur absolue ou c'est le manque à gagn
c'està-dire de quoi sont privés les
salariés et de quoi serait réellement
privé qui compte autant pour un salarié
que l'éducation que le VO que les
vacances que améliorer son quotidien et
comment pourrait le traduire pour un
actionnaire serait intéressant en tout
cas je vois que vous nous attendons de
voir comme cela a été dit et
l'amendement dit qu'il convient de
s'assurer que ceci que les actionnaires
et les mandataires sociaux ne se
dérobent pas leurs obligations en
invoquant ce qui est écrit dans le texte
le respect des compétences des organes
dans lequel ils siègent ou sont
représentés merci chers collègues je
vais demander l'avis de la commission
sur l'amendement prés par Monsieur de
cessar oui merci madame la Présidente je
je voudrais être sûr d'avoir bien
compris le sens de cette amendement que
que j'ai du mal à appréhender vous
proposez de supprimer dans l'alinéa 11
dans le respect je cite les mots dans le
respect des compétences des organes
d'administration et de
surveillance la disposition selon
laquelle les mandataires sociaux et les
actionnaires doivent fournir des efforts
proportionnés à ceux de demander aux
autres salariés et Dieu sait si dans les
auditions des organisations syndicales
ils ont insisté nos interlocuteurs sur
ce point d'ajouter dans le respect des
compétences des organes d'administration
et de surveillance me semble être un
simple rappel des règles de procédure du
droit des entreprises c'est pourquoi je
ne peux pas vous suivre sur votre
proposition merci monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le ministre même avis
merci vote réservé le 124 le 524 n'est
pas défendu le 62 monsieur le
cessar bah oui obbligé de partir moi
aussi parce que j' en fait trop
he ouais qu'il revienne mon cher
com cet amendement vise à renforcer la
sécurité des travailleurs une fois
l'accord de maintien dans l'emploi arriv
à son terme je propose au nom du groupe
écologiste qu'une fois la durée
d'application de l'accord arrivve à son
terme les salariés ne puissent être
licenciés pendant une période au moins
équivalente à celle de l'accord car en
l'état l'accord de maintien dans
l'emploi permet d'éviter les
licenciements uniquement pendant la
durée de validité de l'accord et au prix
je vous le rappelle d'un grand nombre de
sacrifices de la part des salariés mais
qu'en est-il alors une fois l'accord
arrivé à son terme la réponse est très
simple les salariés pourront être
licenciés ils auront donc consenti à à
des baisses de salaire à une
modification de leur temps de travail et
ce pendant potentiellement 2 ans pour
finalement se retrouver au chômage cet
amendement correspond à la philosophie
même des défenseurs de cette loi
puisqu'il propose d'instaurer une réelle
Flexi sécurité et j'insiste sur le mot
sécurité en effet si l'employeur peut
baisser les salaires et modifier
l'organisation du travail pendant du
travail pendant la période donnée si les
salariés sont donc flexibles il est tout
à fait normal pour ne pas dire
absolument indispensable que les
salariés que les salariés soi réellement
sécurisé sur leur emploi nous souhaite
nous souhaitons redonner un sens au mot
mes chers collègues nous souhaitons que
les collègues que les accords de
maintien dans l'emploi servent
effectivement à maintenir les emplois
c'est pourquoi je soutiens au nom du
groupe écologiste cet amendement merci
Monsieur de cessard l'avis de la
commission monsieur le rapporteur oui
l'avis hlas sera d'une simplicité
biblique défavorable puisque vous
proposez de de doubler tous les systèmes
de prote setion je crois que l'accord
est équilibré il s'agit d'un accord
tenons-nous en à l'accord
défavorable merci même avis merci
beaucoup vote
réservé je suis saisie de plusieurs
amendements faisant l'objet d'une
discussion commune le 517 rectifié
madame
Bruguière merci oui merci le projet de
loi prévoit le cas où le salarié
refuserait l'application à son contrat
de travail de stipulation de l'accord de
maintien dans l'emploi ce refus entraîne
donc un licenciement or le projet de loi
qualifie celui-ci de licenciement
économique mais individuel pourtant
l'article L 1222-8 du Code du travail
issu de la loi au BR 2 dispose que le
refus d'un sal d'un salarié pardon d'une
modification de son contrat de travail
résultant de l'application d'un accord
en l'occurrence un accord de réduction
de la durée de travail son licenciement
est un licenciement qui ne repose pas
sur un un motif économique la
qualification à licenciement économique
individuel retenu par le projet de loi
pose un problème en cas de refus d'au
moins 10 salariés normalement il s'agit
alors d'un licenciement collectif alors
que le projet de loi prévoit d'en faire
une addition de licenciement individuel
ce que n'acceptera certainement pas la
Chambre sociale de la Cour de cassation
or si le juge estime qu'il y a
licenciement collectif celui-ci
entraînera un plan de sauvegarde de
l'emploi et des obligations très
contraignantes pour l'entreprise le
projet de loi manquerait ainsi total C
objectifs de simplification et de
flexibilité le présent amendement vise
donc à rétablir la qualification de
licenciement pour motif personnels merci
merci Madame
Brugière le 604 monsieur de
cessard cet amendement concerne le
caractère individuel pour licenciement
du licenciement pour motif économique
introduit dans ce présent article
lorsqu'un ou plusieurs salariés refuse
application de l'accord de maintien dans
l'emploi leur contrat de travail le
projet de loi qui est actuellement
soumis à discussion propose que leur
licenciement soit prononcé selon les
modalités d'un licenciement individuel
pour motif économique or cette
disposition contr contrevient non
seulement au droit du travail en vigueur
dans notre pays mais en outre au droit
européen qui précise tous deux qu'un
licenciement pour motifs économique qui
concerne plus de 10 salarié est un
licenciement collectif c'est le sens de
l'article L 123325 du Code du travail
qui prévoit qu'en cas de refus de la
part d' moins 10 salariés d'une
modification d'un élément essentiel de
leur contrat de travail leur
licenciement est soumis au disposition
d'un d'un licenciement collectif pour
motif économique c'est également le sens
de la directive européenne 98 59 Ce du
20 juillet 98 la procédure de
licenciement collectif est davantage
protectrice pour les salariés
puisqu'elle prévoit notamment que
l'employeur réunisse et consulte les
membres du comité d'entreprise ou les
délégués du personnel en plus d'être une
atteinte aux droits sociaux des
travailleurs cette disposition n'est pas
juridiquement acceptable c'est pourquoi
je demande la suppression du terme
individuel figurant figurant à l'alinéa
17 du présent article merci chers
collègues le 518 rectifi monsieur
Cambon merci euh madame la Présidente
donc nous revenons sur le même sujet
avec un amendement de repli le projet de
loi prévoit donc le cas où le salarié
refuserait l'application à son contrat
de travail de l'accord de maintien dans
l'emploi se refus entraîne un
licenciement qui serait s le texte
économique un amendement précédent a
proposé de revenir sur la qualification
du licenciement en accord avec l'article
L
12228 du Code du travail issu de la loi
au comme j'ai eu l'occasion de le
rappeler tout à l'heure et ce
conformément à la jurisprudence donc à
défaut cet amendement propose de
supprimer les obligations
d'accompagnement qui sont des formalités
é trop lourde et onéreuse de notre point
de vue pour l'entreprise comme pour la
société et qui serait susceptible de
créer une discrimination vis-à-vis des
salariés qui ont accepté les clauses de
l'accord notamment laallocation
spécifique de reclassement avec 80 % du
salaire pendant 12 mois puis le régime
de l'unedct pendant 24 mois enfin les
minimas
sociaux merci Monsieur Cambon monsieur
le ministre je vous invite à présenter
l'amendement
madame la Présidente c'est un amendement
de mémoire qui remet l'obligation
clairement
de de de ma mémoire
flanche voilà doit prévoir au lieu de
prévoir pour qu'il n'y ait aucune
ambigué sur
l'obligation des mesures
d'accompagnement et de reclassement mais
je répondrai sur certains amendements
sur ce point là aussi merci Monsieur le
Ministre l'amendement 270 monsieur van
lorenberg
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues l'objet de
cet amendement est de préciser que les
modalité de reclassement en cas de
rupture du contrat de travail pour refus
d'un accord de maintien de l'emploi sont
les mêmes que celles applicable en cas
de rupture de contrat de travail pour
refus de mobilité interne voilà je ne
sais ce que vous en
pensez merci Monsieur van lurenberg je
vais demander l'avis de la commission du
rapporteur sur ces amendements en
discussion
communes merci madame la Présidente je
vais essayer d'être synthétique parce
que vous observerez que sur l'accord de
maintien dans l'emploi on retrouve la
même problématique que sur l'accord de
mobilité interne et avec les mêmes
interrogations alors je vais dire à à
Madame
bruguère que vous souhaitez que on
qualifie le licenciement dans le cadre
du plan de maintien d'emploi pour la
personne qui aurait refusé cet accord
qu'elle soit licenciée non plus
individuellement à titre économique mais
à titre personnel euh je rappelle ce que
j'ai dit tout à l'heure par rapport à la
Convention 158 de l'Organisation
internationale du travail je rappelle
mes propres propos pardon les propos
d'abord de monsieur le ministre sur la
sécurisation de cet aspect par les soins
du Conseil d'État qui nous a
effectivement recommandé euh pour éviter
ce risque
de de judiciarisation de de cette
affaire de nous en tenir à la
qualification licenciement individuel à
caractère économique et donc soyez tout
à fait rassuré sur le plan juridique
puisque c'est cette inquiétude juridique
qui avait motivé votre amendement c'est
donc un avis défavorable le deème
l'amendement 604 de notre collègue Jean
Desessard lui souhaite qu'on ajoute
l'obligation de mettre en place un PSE
un plan de sauvegarde dans l'emploi si
plus de 10 salariés refusent l'accord et
sont licenciés sur une période de 30
jours
alors cette question nous en avons
longuement débattu il va de soi que elle
serait contraire à l'esprit même de
l'accord de maintien dans l'emploi elle
serait contraire à la définition que
nous souhaitons donner du licenciement à
caractè individuel car ce licenciement
même si d'aventure il devait être
multiplié au-delà de 10 et bien rien ne
doit conduire en tout cas aucun argument
à mettre en place un plan de sauvegarde
de l'emploi nous ne sommes pas du tout
dans un licenciement collectif pour
motif économique c'est d'une autre
nature c'est donc un avis défavorable et
puis le l'argument pardon l'amendement
rectifié de Monsieur
Cardou
lui suggère de supprimer les mesures
d'accompagnement que doit prévoir
l'accord à partir du moment où le
licenciement des salariés qui refusent
l'accord est qualifié d'économique mais
que les règles du PSE sont écartées je
l'ai dit tout à l'heure il paraît
néanmoins logique et c'est en cela que
je trouve que l'accord est équilibré il
paraît néanmoins logique de prévoir des
mesures de reclassement
de façon à ne pas laisser sur le bord du
chemin les les salariés concernés et
c'est donc un avis défavorable à cette
mesure proposée l'amendement
667 proposé par le gouvernement pour
rendre plus impératif
l'obligation je ne m'y opposerai pas
bien entendu l'amendement
euh qui vise à de monsieur valerenberg
qui vise à
compléter à adapter les mesures de
reclassement vous souhaitez c'est c'est
la même chose que tout à l'heure aligner
les mesures de reclassement d'un salarié
après avoir refusé l'application d'un
accord de maintien dans l'emploi sur les
règles prévues en cas de refus d'un
accord de mobilité interne à l'article
10 alors la tentation est grande en
effet d'aligner les règles pour ces deux
disp positif néanmoins elles répondent à
des logiques différentes l'adaptation
des règles de reclassement dans l'accord
de mobilité s'explique par la nécessité
d'éviter des situations ubuesque en
obligeant par exemple l'employeur a
proposé un salarié une mobilité à 100 km
de chez lui un poste de reclassement à
250 km je crois que il convient selon
moi de garder la rédaction actuelle qui
a mérite d'être équilibr bré qui propose
les bonnes mesures d'accompagnement au
bon niveau et c'est donc un avis
défavorable je crois
avoir regarder l'ensemble des
amendements oui merci monsieur le
rapporteur l'avis du Gouvernement
monsieur le ministre sur cette série
d'amendements l'avis du Gouvernement
sera défavorable sur cette série
d'amendements qui sont d'ailleurs de
nature différente au fond certains
cherchent à tirer d'un côté d'autres
cherche à tirer de l'autre et bien vous
savez quel est mon
repère l'accord que dit l'accord
que dit l'accord en cas de refus du
salarié des mesures prévues par l'accord
la rupture de son contrat de travail qui
en résulte s'analyse en un licenciement
économique donc non à tous les
amendements qui voudrai passer au
licenciement de caractère personnel dont
la cause réelle et sérieuse est attestée
par l'accord précité c'est un
licenciement économique mais de
caractère individuel et lorsqu'il y en a
plus de 10 nous ne retombons pas dans un
PSE c'était d'ailleurs un des objectifs
de simplification de cet article là et
donc au nom de l'équilibre de l'accord
je dis aux un comme aux autres que je
suis défavorable à le amendements merci
Monsieur le Ministre ces amendements
sont donc en vote réservé j'appelle le
63 613 monsieur de
cessar toujours à l'article
12 les accords de mainen dans l'emploi
devront être majoritaires c'est-à-dire
signé par des organisations syndicales
ayant recueilli au moins 50 % des
suffrages exprimés au premier tour des
dernières élections des délégués
syndicaux mais si l'entreprise n'a pas
de délégué syndical l'accord sera signé
par un représentant élu du personnel
mandaté par des organisations syndicales
le problème c'est que ces organisations
syndicales mandantes ne sont pas tenu
d'être majoritaire cet amendement vise
donc à palier cette carence du texte les
accords de en de l'emploi sont d'une
telle importance qu'ils ne peuvent être
le résultat d'autre chose que d'un
consensus cela a été dit pour se faire
le caractère majoritaire de l'accord
doit être respecté même lorsque
l'organisation syndicale n'est pas
directement signataire mais seulement
mandante merci chers collègu l'avis de
la commission monsieur le rapporteur sur
cet amendement
613 merci madame la Présidente cet
amendement obligerait donc les les
syndicats qui mandatent un salarié à
obtenir au 50 % des suffrages exprimés
au niveau de la branche moi je pense
qu'il faut être dans un système simple
ce que j'ai retenu et et ce qui doit
constituer le cadre de référence c'est
que l'accord de maintien dans l'emploi
il doit recueillir et c'est ça sa
garantie majeure plus de 50 % de
l'accord des
syndicats pour que cet accord soit
effectif et donc cette garantie me me
semble suffisante aller au-delà
risque de bouleverser le droit du
mandatement dans le code du travail et
ce n'est pas souhaitable défavorable
merci Monsieur le Ministre même avis
merci le 605 monsieur de cessar toujours
à l'article
12 cet amendement vise à étendre la
saisine du juge aux organisations
syndical non signataire de l'accord le
dialogue social a été le maître de ce
projet de loi il convient donc que
toutes les voix soient entendues afin
que le respect des droits des salariés
puisse être effectif je propose donc que
le juge puisse être saisi par l'ensemble
des organisations syndicales et non pas
seulement par les organisations
signataires des accords de maintien de
l'emploi dans l'emploi pour se prononcer
sur la suspension des 10 accords puis
sur leur poursuite ou leur résiliation
cet amendement poursuit de buts
essentiels il vise d'une part à
promouvoir la démocratie sociale et le
dialogue entre l'ensemble des acteurs
sociaux il garantit d'autre part aux
salariés une meilleure protection de
leurs droits et une capacité de contrôle
plus plus étendue sur la nécessité des
accords de maintien dans l'emploi si je
me permettais un
parallèle au niveau politique si on
suivait ce qui est dans le texte
aujourd'hui ne pourrait se présenter aux
élections que ceux qui ont voté le les
modalités de scrutin c'està-dire ceux
qui auraiit pas été d'accord ben on leur
dit vous pouvez pas vous présenter c'est
quand même un peu fort c'est-à-dire il y
a des accords qui ont été signés et
devant le juge pour vérifier
l'application ben il n'y a pas que les
organisations signataires hein parce que
corit tendance justement à fermer un peu
les yeux pour se justifier mais
l'ensemble des organisations et c'est le
juge qui tranche bien entendu merci
chers collègues l'avis de la commission
monsieur le
rapporteur merci madame la Présidente je
crois que c cet amendement s'il était
appliqué créerait une situation assez
hubuesque dans les entreprises imaginez
on aurait d'un côté des syndicats qui
signne l'accord et qui sont majoritaires
et de l'autre les les syndicats qui
auraient été minoritaires qui pourraient
saisir le juge pour annuler
l'accord c'est ah cette
situation si elle devait se mettre en
place serait pas saine et découragerait
évidemment l'action des syndicats qui
jouent le jeu du dialogue social
constructif c'est c'est une situation
que je n'ose même pas imag in par contre
ensuite les salariés nous l'avons dit
tout à l'heure ont toujours la
possibilité à titre personnel de refuser
cet accord et ensuite également toutes
les voies de recours sont ouvertes et
possibles mais celle-là me semble ne pas
être dans la ligne de l'esprit
évidemment de ce texte
défavorable merci Monsieur le Ministre
même avis
merci l'amendement 264 c'est monsieurv
lorenberg non allez-y chers
collègues merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur mes chers collègues l'objet de
cet amendement est de préciser qu'en cas
de rupture du contrat de travail
consécutive et la suspension de l'accord
de maintien de l'emploi les indemnités
prises en compte sont non seulement les
indemnités légales mais aussi les
indemnités conventionnelles ce qui
semble tomber sous le sens il s'agit
sans doute de corriger ici un
oubli si monsur monsieur capo canellaa
l'avis de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur sur l'amendement
264 le le je voudrais rappeler que le
nouvel article L 51 256 est protecteur
des droits des salariés puisqu'il
prévoit le calcul des indemnités légales
et de l'allocation assurance chômage qui
se fait soit sur la base de la
rémunération du salarié au moment de la
rupture soit sur la base de la
rémunération antérieure à la conclusion
de l'accord si cette base est plus
avantageuse pour lui les auteurs de
l'amendement souhaite que cette logique
soit appliquée également aux indemnités
conventionnelles on ne peut que donner
une suite
favorable merci monsieur le ministre je
seraai plus court que le rapporteur le
Gouvernement est favorable à cet
amendement de précision qui est
bienvenu merci monsieur le ministre
ces deux amendements ainsi que l'article
12 sont réservés en matière de vote nous
arrivons à l'article à l'article
13 alors une série d'amendements en
discussion commune le 606 monsieur de
cessar ah non discussion commune
excusez-nous il a fallu les reclasser
mais allez-y chers collègues
il s'agit de l'article 13 dans la
section 3 renforcer l'encadrement des
licenciements collectifs et instaurer
une obligation de recherge d'
reprpreneur en cas de fermeture de site
nous voulons rédiger ainsi cette Linéa
41 en absence d'accord sur les modalités
d'accompagnement Le comité d'entreprise
peut exercer un droit de véau suspensif
un droit de véau suspensif une procédure
arbitrale sous la responsabilité de la
Direction régionale des entreprises de
la concurrence de la consommation du
travail et de l'emploi est alors engagé
dans un délai d'un
mois l'objet de cet amendement est de
donner un un droit de vetau suspensif au
comité d'entreprise en cas d'absence
d'accord sur les modalités
d'accompagnement merci Monsieur de
cessar l'avis de monsieur le
rapporteur merci madame la Présidente ce
droit de vetto n'a pas été prévu dans
l'accord je voudrais rappeler aussi que
la procédure arbitrale que souhaitent
les auteurs de l'amendement sera en
quelque sorte satisfaite par les
dispositions du projet de loi qui non
mais écoutez-moi jusqu'au bout qui
renforce les missions confié à la
directe et donc de ce point de vue je
pense que vos inquiétudes peuvent être
levées défavorables monsieur le ministre
même avis merci Monsieur le Ministre
vote réservé le
549 madame
Laborde oui madame la Présidente
l'article 13 du projet de loi va
réformer les procédures de licenciement
collectifs l'alinée l'alinéa 1 de
l'article
123334 du Code du travail prévoit que le
comité d'entreprise peut recourir à
l'assistance d'un expert comptable en
application de l'article
2325 35 du Code du travail lorsque le
projet de licenciement concerne 10
salariés ou plus dans une même période
de 30our jour dans les entreprises de 50
salariés et plus le texte du projet de
loi complète cette alinéa 1 de l'article
123334 du code en prévoyant que le
comité peut également mandater un expert
comptable pour qu'il apporte toute
analyse utile aux organisations
syndicale pour mener la négociation
prévue à l'article 1233 241
l'élaboration des actes juridiques met
en œuvre des compétences qui sont celles
des avocats cet amendement prévoit donc
que le comité puisse mandater un expert
comptable et également un avocat les
honoraires des professionnels ainsi
mandatés seront à la charge de
l'entreprise merci Madame Laborde l'avis
de la commission monsieur le rapporteur
oui merci madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues il s'agit du même amendement
que nous avons vu tout à l'heure et qui
a été présenté par vos collègues pour
lequel j'avais sollicité l'avis du
Gouvernement monsieur le ministre nous a
répondu je crois que nous pouvons nous
en tenir à cet avis qui était
formellement défavorable mais dans
l'esprit tout à fait favorable merci
monsieur le rapporteur même avis merci
beaucoup merci le
630 le 635 rectifier madame
Ruger merci madame la Présidente C cet
amendement vise à clarifier la nature de
la consultation du comité d'entreprise
sur le dispositif de reclassement si la
consultation du comité d'entreprise est
importante l'exigence d'un avis
favorable peut être de nature à rendre
ce dispositif praticable peu praticable
cette mesure vise à accélérer les
propositions de mobilité aux salariés
concernés sans attendre merci madame la
Présidente rugère l'avis de la
commission monsieur le
rapporteur merci madame la Présidente
euh l'alinéa
72 tel qu'il est rédigé n vocation à
être utilisé que dans de rares cas il
n'est pas commun en effet que le comité
d'entreprise encourage la mobilité
interne alors même que les consultations
sur le projet de licenciement économique
ne sont pas terminés l'obligation d'un
avis favorable me semble en l'espèce
effectivement indispensable c'est donc
un avis défavorable sur votre
amendement merci même avis merci
Monsieur le Ministre vote réservé le le
551 rectifié Madame La Borde madame la
Présidente défendrait également les 550
rectifiés et 552 rectifiés parfait donc
jusqu'à présent le juge vérifie
uniquement si le motif économique
justifiant un licenciement collectif est
fondé mais il ne vérifie pas s'il est
réel et sérieux la nullité du
licenciement peut donc être prononcé en
cas d'irrégularité de la procédure mais
pas en cas de défaut de justification
économique réelle pourtant cette période
économique et sociale très difficile
pour beaucoup de salariés il nous faut
être par particulièrement attentif à la
sauvegarde de l'emploi cet amendement
vise donc à ce que l'autorité
administrative s'assure que le motif
économique est réel et sérieux il
s'appuie pour cela sur un arrêt de la
Cour d'appel de Paris du 12 mai 2011
dans l'affaire Viveo qui a estimé que le
défaut de motif économique pouvait
conduire lui aussi à prononcer la nulité
du licenciement comme vous le savez
cette décision de la Cour d'appel a été
cassée par la Cour de cassation par un
arrêt du 3 mai 2012
dans ces conditions il nous paraît
judicieux de préciser dans la loi que
les juridictions seront habilité à
apprécier la validité de l'accord
collectif majoritaire ou du document
élaboré par l'employeur tant vis-à-vis
de la procédure suivie que de
l'exactitude du motif économique merci
chers collègues pour la pour la clarté
vous avez présenté le 551 rectifié le
552 rectifi le 550 rectifié les trois
merci sur le 5 rectifier monsieur le
rapporteur merci madame la Présidente je
ferais simplement observer à ma collègue
madame Laborde mais avec beaucoup
d'amitié qu'elle fait un contresens elle
fait un contresens parce que c'est au
Conseil des prudommes qu'il revient de
contrôler si le licenciement repose sur
une cause réelle et sérieux et sérieuse
Laan n'a pas prévu de revenir sur ce
point on on peut avoir un point de vue
sur sur cette affaire mais en tout cas
c'est le le contrôle de l'administration
lui ne porte pas sur le motif économique
du
licenciement les les rôles et les
pouvoirs sont clairement répartis et
définis avis défavorable merci Monsieur
le
Ministre merci vote réservé le 621
monsieur de
cessard c'était le c'était est le même
que
Madame
6211 c'est
ça l'article 13 tel qu'il est rédigé
affaiblit fortement l'encadrement du
licenciement économique par les textes
législatifs ainsi que les jurisprudences
le présent amendement vise à que
l'autorité administrative s'assure que
le motif économique justifiant le
licenciement collectif est réel et
sérieux merci Monsieur de cessa l'avis
de la commission sur ces deux
amendements identiques j'ai déjà répondu
à Madame labord même réponseord même
avis me lever dans un cas l'autre mais
même avis donc que les choses soient
claires l'autorité administrative aura
apprécié l'ensemble du dossier
l'ensemble du dossier pour donner son
habilitation elle pourra je reviens pas
dans les détails mais elle devra
éventuellement rentrer en négociation
avec l'entreprise c'est là d'ailleurs
que se trouve le la réponse à un des
grands engagements du Président de la
République pendant la campagne éctorale
le
renchérissement des licenciements entre
guillemets boursiers c'est dans cette
négociationl pourra faire monter les
prix si euh l'objectif de l'entreprise
apparaît comme étant purement
de rentabilité supérieure pour gagner
encore plus d'argent bien donc les
choses sont claires
le contrôle du motif économique réel et
sérieux c'est les prudomes c'est par ce
biais là d'ailleurs quand vous parlez de
l'arrêt vivo c'est un arrêt vivo à la
suite d'une décision de conseil des
prudomes et c'est donc dans ce cadre là
et dans ce cadre là seulement que ce
contrôle sera fait merci Monsieur le
mini minist sur ces deux amendements le
vote est réservé le 607 monsieur de
cessar pas
débre un vote
bloqué article 13 remplacer mot 21 par
le mot
30 cet amendement vise à donner
davantage de temps à l'administration
pour donner sa décision de validation à
l'employeur afin de disposer de délis
pour en étudier la
pertinence je comprends qu'il faille des
procédures accélérées enfin pas toujours
je comprends pas toujours je veux dire
mais là en 21 jours c'est pas beaucoup
30 vous voulez me dire non plus mais il
faut bien mettre une date donc on
propose 30 jours au lieu de 21 merci
chers collègues monsieur le
rapporteur oui merci madame la
Présidente chers collègues question
d'appréciation mais il me semble que 21
jours pour pour
homologuer un plan unilatéral de
l'employeur on est dans ce cas de figure
me semble suffisant d'autant que et
c'est un point qui a été précisé à
l'Assemblée nationale si je ne m'abuse
d'autant que l'administration commence
son contrôle en amont pendant la phase
de consultation du CE ça veut dire que
son délai effectivement est encore plus
large et donc je rappelle aussi par
ailleurs que le le constat de car
se fait en 8 jours aujourd'hui donc vous
voyez que cette règle des des 3 semaines
est équilibrée c'est donc
défavorable merci l'avis du Gouvernement
monsieur le ministre oui il y a eu tout
un débat sur cette durée bien c'est tout
à fait légitime que ce débat a eu lieu
bon je rappelle que l'accord lui-même
prévoit 21 jours donc je m'en tiens là
aussi à l'accord mais 21 jours tout seul
ça pourrait paraître court 3 xis 7 3
semaines mais c'est pas 21 jours la la
réalité c'est que l'administration comme
vient de le dire le rapporteur
commencera à travailler dès le départ
elle aura connaissance de dès le départ
de l'élaboration du du plan d'ailleurs
comme aujourd'hui je vous rappelle
qu'aujourd'hui l'administration fait un
certain nombre de remarques mais elle
n'a aucun pouvoir demain elle pourra
faire des remarques elle pourra négocier
et elle aura un pouvoir le pouvoir de
dire oui ou de dire non c'est une des
avancées considérables de ce texte comme
nous allons nous débattons rapidement je
ne peux pas souligner à ce point à quel
point c'est une avancée considérable de
ce texte l'État est de retour l'état
arbitre l'État garant c'est quelque
chose d'absolument décisif et qui sera
mise en œuvre grâce à cet accord et
c'est un progrès parce que c'est un
accord de progrès monsieur
Desessard merci Monsieur le Ministre
vote
réservé le 629 rectifier madame rugière
oui madame la Présidente l'objet de cet
amendement est d'instaurer sur sur la
base d'un document transmis par
l'employeur en même temps que la
convocation à la première réunion du
comité d'entreprise rcrit avec réponse
explicite de l'administration sous 8
jours à défaut du respect de ce délai la
réponse est considérée comme positive
merci merci Madame Bruguière l'avis de
la commission monsieur le
rapporteur chers collègues il ne me
semble pas à ce stade de prévoir une
procédure de réscrit en amont de la
consultation du comité d'entreprise en
fait l'employeur pourra très bien
interroger la directe en amont sur des
points de droit particuliers sans qu'il
soit nécessaire de mettre en place une
phase lourde et et formelle de rcrit
d'ailleurs les échanges qui auront lieu
pendant la phase de consultation du CE
qui durera entre 2 et 4 mois serviront
précisément à éviter toute mauvaise
interprétation des textes législatifs et
réglementaires c'est donc un avis
défavorable merci même avis merci vote
réservé je suis à l'amendement 650 de la
commission des lois il s'agit d'un
amendement de coordination vous validez
monsieur le rapporteur très bien merci
l'avis de du gouvernement l'amendement
oui pu je
excusez-moi ça va trop vite non non ça
va pas trop vite ça va un rythme tout à
fait normal vous voulez je donne une un
avis c'était avis favorable s réserve de
rectification alors mon avis est celui
du retrait parce que je je vais vous
présenter un amendement numéro
668 qui répond à cette préoccupation
donc il est appelé un peu plus tard mais
je peux permettre peut-être madame la
Présidente avec autorisation de le
présenter cet amendement vise à
articuler le délai dans lequel
l'administration se prononce sur le PSE
en procédure de sauvegarde avec le délai
de prise en charge par l'AGS un mois
suivant le jugement qui arrête le plan
de sauvegarde afin de protéger les
salariés il convient donc de prévoir des
délais raccourcis pour la validation de
ou l'homologation à à l'image de ce que
prévoit le projet de loi pour les
entreprises en redressement judiciaire
et comme le suggérait monsieur Gorse
dans son amendement numéro 650 donc si
Monsieur Gorse était là je lui
demanderais de retirer son amendement si
quelqu'un peut le faire à sa place
serait très volontiers au profit de
l'amendement numéro 668 du gouvernement
qui répond de manière encore plus
parfaite aux préoccupations du
rapporteur de la commission des lois
merci monsieur le ministre je vais
demander l'avis de la commission sur le
668 qui vient d'être présenté par
Monsieur le
Ministre favorable et pas d'objection
bien sûr merci monsieur le rapporteur le
672 le le
672 monsieur jeanerau coordination
coordination monsieur le
ministre monsieur le ministre monsieur
coordination c'est bon merci euh
651 de la commission des lois de
Monsieur Gorse monsieur le genau vous le
présentez c'est la même chose que
l'autre h
défendu donc il le reprenne pas
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
ministre parfait parfait qui est là qui
a déjà été présent par le 668 qui a été
présenté et qui a reçu un avis favorable
de la commission nous passons au 608
monsieur de
cessar cet amendement est important il
vise à supprimer la 2è et la 3è phrase
de l'alinéa 162 je rappelle
l'alinéa le tribunal administratif
statut dans un délai de 3 mois 3 mois
les procédures de la justice c'est
formidable maintenant si à l'issue de ce
délai c'est pas prononcé ou en cas
d'appel le litige est porté devant la
Cour administrative d'appel qui statue
d'un délai de 3 mois la justice
fonctionne
admirablement si à l'issue de ce délai
ne s'est pas prononcé ou en cas de
pourvoie en cassation le litige est
porté devant le Conseil d'État oui
aujourd'hui les procédures judiciaires
sont trop longues mais le projet de loi
répond de la mauvaise façon ne répond
pas à l'engorgement de la justice en
rabaissant les garanties offertes au
justiciables non si on voulait discuter
ce qu'il faud avant tout c'est une
réforme du ministère de la Justice au
ministère de la Justice plus de moyens
dans les tribunaux et cetera et cetera
et aujourd'hui dans le texte les trois
étapes tribunal administratif cour
d'appel et Conseil d'État ont toute leur
importance et permettent justement de
faire appel d'une décision prise par
l'échelon inférieur si on accélère
quasiment si on accélère c'est quasiment
supprimer les étapes il n'y a plus de
recours possible cela s'apparente à ind
déit de justice et notre amendement vise
à y remédier merci chers collègues
l'avis de la commission sur cet
amendement l'avis de la commission
madame la Présidente sera simple parce
que ce que nous propose notre collègue
est est radical ça vise à supprimer les
les instances d'appel et effectivement
je ne vois pas comment ce que vous
propose ce que vous proposer peut-être
davantage protecteur pour les salariés
je pense même que dans la mesure où on
s'élève dans dans l'ordre juridictionnel
a priori et on le constate
statistiquement j'ai un long
argumentaire je je je je vous en
épargnerai moins les tribunaux sont
surchargés je crois qu'il faut conserver
cette hiérarchie et ces possibilités
d'appel dans l'intérêt des des salariés
donc c'est des favorable
merci Monsieur le Ministre l'avis du
Gouvernement ou j'ai bien vu que
l'objectif est de supprimer les délais
qui sont imposés au tribunal
administratif et au à la cour
administrative d'appel pour juger je
rappelle qu'il existe d'autres
contentieux où il y a des délais de
cette nature donc on ninente rien nous
sommes dans un domaine où il est de
l'intérêt de tous de tous du côté de
l'entreprise comme du côté du salarié
d'avoir une réponse juridique précise
mais le plus rapidement possible
définitive nul n'a intérêt à attendre
attendre attendre à allonger les délais
et donc c'est vraiment de l'intérêt de
tout le monde et sur un point où votre
interrogation est parfaitement justifiée
la juridiction administrative
aura-t-elle les moyen de répondre dans
ces délais dans de bonnes conditions des
conditions de qualité je voudrais
apporter deux réponses
premièrement pour ceux qui connaissent
un peu les juridictions administratives
ce ne sont plus du tout les mêmes délis
que ceux qu'on pouvait connaître il y a
10 ans ou 15 ans les juridictions
administratives juge maintenend dans des
délais qui peuvent être extrêmement
rapides et deuxièmement depuis le début
de la conception de ce texte je
travaille avec le Conseil d'État qui a
la responsabilité de l'ensemble de la
juridiction administrative à la mise en
place d'un certain nombre de formations
d'un certain nombre de mécanismes de
dans chacune
des juridiction concerné pour que tout
soit prêt pour qu'on puisse examiner de
manière précise et irréprochable du
point de vue juridiques les recours
aussi bien des entreprises que des
salariés oui merci Monsieur le le
ministre vote réservé sur le 608 le 550
rectifié madame Laborde ah oui c'est
vrai qu'il est défendu merci le 508 du
groupe madame Goulet oui madame le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues ça fait trois fois qu'on nous
explique que cet amendement est
satisfait dans le principe mais qu'il
est pas dans le dans l'accord donc je le
retire merci merci Madame
Goulet l'amendement
673 monsieur jeanraau au nom de la
commission des affaires sociales c'est
un amendement de cohérence
oui très bien monsieur le
ministre favorable merci euh monsieur le
ministre je vous invite à présenter le
671 également tout fait l'avis de la
commission merci bien nous arrivons à la
fin de l'article 13 les amendements de
l'article 13 plus
l'article le vote est
réservé nous arrivons à l'article 14 à
l'amendement 609 présenté par notre
collègue de
cessar s'agit d'un article sur les
repreneurs obigation de chercher un
repreneur est une excellente initiative
mise en place par le projet de loi on
voit trop souvent des entreprises et
leurs salariés délaissé alors qu'elles
ont un réel potentiel certaines peuvent
être converties dans un domaine plus
dynamique c'est d'ailleurs ce que nous
prenons avec la transition écologique de
l'économie c'est une chance pour
maintenir l'emploi dans un bassin de vie
je salue donc l'article 14 à cet égard
sependant il apparaît que cette
recherche d'repreneur n'intervient que
pour les entreprises de plus de 1000
salariés ce qui n c'est d'ailleurs pas
prévu dans la
ni nous souhaitons que cette recherche
de repreneur soit effective des 300
salariés au-delà de cette taille
l'entreprise a assez
conséquen assez conséquente pour
bénéficier du
dispositif et bien sûr ce sont pas les
salariés concernés qui me
contrediront merci chers collègues
l'avis de la
commission merci madame la Présidente je
vrais dire à mon collègue essar que la
question qu'il pose est intéressante et
elle me paraît méritée et c'est ce que
je souhaite faire de de solliciter
l'avis du gouvernement en effet vous
l'avez dit le le point 6 de l' ne fixait
aucun seuil d'effectif pour l'obligation
de trouver un repreneur mais le seuil de
1000 salariés elle mérite d'être celui
utilisé pour obliger les entreprises qui
possèdent qui procède pardon à de grands
licenciements économiques à conclure une
convention de
revitalisation par ces convention
l'employeur doit prendre des mesures
significatives si l'on se contentait de
baisser le seuil à 300 salariés dans
l'article 14 du projet de loi sans
toucher au seuil de 1000 salariés pour
les conventions de
revitalisation il est probable que
l'administration perdrait une arme de
dissuasion contre les entreprises et la
portée de l'article 14 serait donc du
coup limitée faute de sanction c'est
pourquoi je sollicite sur ce point
l'expertise du gouvernement merci chers
collègues l'avis du Gouvernement je sais
pas s'il aura l'expertise mais en
toutous les cas il prêt à vous répondre
de manière très détaillée les
entreprises qui sont concernées par C
sont celles entrant dans le champ de
l'obligation de
revitalisation il s'agit donc des
entreprises sans conditions de taille du
moment qu'elles appartiennent à un
groupe de plus de 1000 salariés en
Europe un site industriel de 100
personnes constitué en société
juridiquement autonome est donc couvert
par l'obligation de recherche de
repreneur si la société appartient à un
groupe de plus de 1000 salariés la
recherche d'enrepreneur est une action
anticipée visant à maintenir la vitalité
économique d'un territoire et les
efforts de recherche d'repreneur peuvent
être valorisés dans les conventions de
revitalisation et il est très important
de maintenir ce lien merci monsieur le
ministre ministre vote réservé ainsi que
le vote sur l'article 14 nous arrivons à
l'article
15 ça c'est en discussion commune des
amendements en discussion commune
monsieur de cessar le
622ut méfier faut se
méfier cet amendement vis revenir sur
une rupture d'égalité qu'a introduit
l'article 15 du projet de loi je cite
l'alinéa qui nous pose problème
l'employeur peut privilégier un de ces
critères à condition de tenir compte de
l'ensemble des autres critères prévus au
présent article c'est très clair he donc
en réalité C aliné cet alinéa fait fait
référence à l'article L 12335 du Code du
travail qui prévoit que lorsque
l'employeur procède à un licenciement
collectif pour motif économique et en
l'absence de tion au accord collectif de
travail applicable il définit les
critères retenus pour fixer l'ordre des
licenciements après consultation du
comité d'entreprise ou à défaut de
délégués du personnel ces critères
prennent notamment en compte les charges
de famille en particulier celles des
parents isolé l'ancienneté de service
dans l'établissement ou l'entreprise la
situation des salariés qui présente des
caractéristiques sociales rendant leur
réinsertion professionnelle
particulièrement difficile notamment
celle des personnes handicapées et des
salariés âgés les qualités
professionnelles appréciées par
catégorie laisser le choix à l'employeur
de privilégier un de ces critères
s'inaurer une réelle discrimination et
se moquer en réalité de ces critères ils
permettent pourtant de se soucier des
situations sociales liées à la personne
madame Génisson avait d'ailleurs en
commission des Affaires social alerté
sur cette alinéa en indiquant que
l'appréciation des qualités
professionnelles pouvait être
discriminante à l'égard des femmes mon
amendement propose donc de supprimer ces
alinéas qui n'apportent rien mis à part
de l'ambigué quant à son application
merci chers
collègues le 262 présenté par Monsieur
vanlorenberg9 269 voilà
oui 269 merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues l'objet de cet amendement est
d'insister sur les critères qualité
professionnel à prendre en compte par
l'employeur pour déterminer l'ordre des
licenciements dans le cadre d'un
licenciement collectif pour motif
économique ce critère est d'ailleurs
l'un des quatre qui était listé qui est
listé dans l'article L 12 335 du code du
travail et il ne s'agit donc pas en
l'occurrence de modifier l'état de droit
mais de revenir à la lettre de l'an par
lequel les partenaires sociaux
signataires avaient
entendu souligner l'importance de ce
critère pour l'avenir de l'entreprise
lorsque celle-ci rencomte des
difficultés économiques qui la
conduisent à devoir ajuster ses ses
effectifs c'est une façon et je pense
que vous en êtes bien conscient de
protéger les jeunes les jeunes en
particulier qualifiés dans l'entreprise
et les seniors qui sont parfois parce
que les plus récents dans l'entreprise
ou les plus anciens les plus visés par
les licenciements économiques donc
monsieur le ministre j'aimerais vous
entendre sur ce point
merci chers
collègues l'amendement suivant est
présenté par Madame Brugère c'est un
amendement
identique vous
pensez exactement le même c'est pas la
peine que je le présente alors mais si
vous voulez non non non absolument non
c' c'était pour me rassurer que c'était
bien le l'article 23 l' dans son article
23 ainsi que le projet de loi initial
prévoyait de privilég dans l'ordre des
licenciements le critère des qualités
professionnell des salariés à la
condition de tenir compte de l'ensemble
des autres critères il est écrit en
toute lettre dans l'exposé des motifs
qu' s'agit de reprendre et consolider
une jurisprudence de la Cour de
cassation cependant à l'Assemblée
nationale cette disposition a été
supprimée par un amendement de la
délégation au droits des femmes pour des
raisons assez surprenantes en effet la
délégation donne la préférence à une
appréciation au cas par cas et estime
qu'user du critère des qualités
professionnelles signifie user d'un
critère dont il a été constaté qu'il est
défavorable aux femmes cette affirmation
laisse perplexe en effet on ne voit pas
pourquoi un employeur est rien recruté
une femme pour ses qualités
professionnelles estimerit par la suite
que le fait d'être une femme diminue ses
capacités alors il est pour le moins
surprenant que les députés et privilégié
cette appréciation au détriment d'une
jurisprudence constante de la Cour de
cassation et de la décision clairement
exprimé par les partenaires sociaux le
présent amendement vise donc de rétablir
l'article dans sa rédaction initiale
merci Monsieur merci chers collègues je
vais demander l'avis de du monsieur le
rapporteur ah non pas encore en
discussion commune il y en a encore
plusieurs le l'amendement 553 madame
Laborde c'est le dernier de la
discussion commune voilà ce n'est pas
tout à fait le même donc nous vous
proposons d'introduire dans la loi une
jurisprudence unanime s'agissant de
l'appréciation des critères d'ordre des
licenciements économiques notre
amendement vise tout d'abord à préciser
que les critères relat à l'ordre des
licenciements s'applique à l'ensemble du
personnel de l'entreprise c'est-à-dire
que l'employeur ne peut pas limiter
l'application de ces critères au niveau
de l'établissement concerné par les
suppressions d'emplois mais bien au
niveau de l'entreprise tout entière
ensuite il précise que les critères
relatifs à l'ordre des licenciements
doivent s'appliquer à l'ensemble des
salariés appartenant à une même
catégorie professionnelle ainsi il a été
jugé que lorsqu'un employeur envisage la
suppression d'impos de plombier il doit
appliquer les critères d'ordre du
licenciement à l'ensemble des plombiers
de l'entreprise et non au seul plombier
du service concerné par une baisse
d'activité la catégorie professionnelle
doit être entendue comme un groupe de
salariés qui exerce au sein de
l'entreprise des fonctions de même
nature supposant une formation
professionnelle commune je vous
remercie merci chers collègues l'avis de
la commission sur ces amendements en
discussion
commune
merci madame la Présidente en fait ces
amendements concernent la question très
importante de l'ordre des critères qui
déterminent le licenciement et collectif
le licenciement
collectif monsieur
Desessard vous proposez la suppression
des
alinéa il faut bien comprendre que cet
article 15 qui nous est proposé ne fait
qu'entériner une jurisprudence constante
de la Cour de cassation qui autorise la
pondération des critères déterminant
l'ordre d'un licenciement collectif en
plein accord d'ailleurs avec l'article
qui traite de cela dans le code du
travail l'article L
12335 l'employeur peut privilégier un
critère parmi d'autres comme les charges
de famille l'ancienneté les qualités
professionnelles à condition c'est très
important de tenir compte en même temps
de l'ensemble des autres critères je ne
peux donc pas vous suivre sur votre
amendement
défavorable bien sûr c'est ce que je
vous aurait demandé et vous l'auriez
retiré
l'amendement de Monsieur vanenberg et de
madame brunère qui sont de même nature
et il vise à réintroduire le critère des
qualités professionnelles dans le
dernier alinéa alors je ne suis pas
favorable à cet amendement pour deux
raisons il est inutile
car en général nous essayons d'éviter
l'utilisation des mots notamment et en
particulier et puis surtout il a
l'inconvénient de mettre
artificiellement en valeur un critère
plutôt qu'un autre pour ces deux raisons
c'est un avis défavorable le
l'amendement 553 rectifié
euh celui présenté par Monsieur mdar
mard pardon il vise à appliquer les
critères aux catégories professionnelles
dont relève les emplois
pardon pardon excusez-moi madame Laborde
excusez-moi oui
la
voilà alors comme dirait monsieur
monsieur Desessard ce serait une demande
de retrait si nous étions dans la
possibilité de pouvoir le faire parce
que la jurisprudence oblige déjà à
apprécier les critères dans la catégorie
professionnelle dans à laquelle
appartient le salarié c'est un arrêt de
la Cour de cassation du 30 juin 93 qui
vous apporte de ce point de vue toutes
les garanties donc
défavorable merci monsieur le rapporteur
l'avis du Gouvernement monsieur le
ministre sur ces amendements oui madame
la présidente mesdames messieurs les
sénateurs sénatrices je ferai un propos
global je donne un avis défavorable sur
l'ensemble de ces amendements d'abord
pour les raisons qui a dit notre
excellent rapporteur et ensuite je
reviens au cœur du sujet au fond ce
qu'ont voulu les partenaires sociaux
c'est ce qu'on appelle la
cristallisation de la jurisprudence à
laquelle vous avez fait tous allusion de
la Cour de cassation du 2 mars 2004 donc
c'est cela qu'ils ont voulu stabiliser
cette décision de la Cour de cassation a
toujours été considérée comme un élément
important important et plutôt comme un
élément de de progrès mais aussi de de
stabilité et donc nous ne voulons pas
toucher à cet équilibre là voilà c'est
ça vraiment la volonté alors je vois
bien certains veulent tirer d'un côté
tirer de l'autre conservons cet
équilibre là c'est celui qui permettra
aux entreprises d'une part et aux
salariés d'autre part d'être à la fois
dans le meilleur fonctionnement et dans
la meilleure protection merci monsieur
le ministre sur ces amendements et
l'article 15 le vote est réservé nous
arrivons à l'article
623 présenté par Monsieur de
cessar il y a deux il y en a deux il y a
le 623 et le
60 qui sont en discussion
commune
oui donc ça concerne la conciliation en
cas de litige lorsqu'il y a une
conciliation l'employeur et le salarié
peuvent convenir une conciliation ou le
bureau de conciliation proposer d'y
mettre de trouver un accord et cet
accord prévoit le versement par
l'employeur au salariés d'une indemnité
forfaitaire dont le montant est
déterminé sans préjudice des indemnités
légales conventionnelles ou
contractuelles en référence à un barê
fixé par décret en fonction de
l'ancienneté du salarié donc nous disons
que le principe d'une indemnité
forfaitaire va à l'encontre de l'article
10 de la Convention 158 de l'OIT qui
oblige le versement d'une indemnité
adéquate donc en contradiction avec le
barem ce barem en fonction de
l'ancienneté limite le pouvoir
d'évaluation du préjudice subi dévolu au
juge le préjudice ne dépendant
d'ailleurs pas uniquement de
l'ancienneté du salarié donc nous
refusons le barem et nous voulons
laisser à l'appréciation du juge et le
versement d'une indemnité adéquate et
cela en application de l'article 10 de
la Convention 158 de
l'OIT merci chers collègu vous voulez
avoir l'amabilité de présenter le second
le 610 oui ce
concerne l'alinéa nous après l'alinéa 3
insérer
un alinéa ainsi rédigé l'absence d'une
des deux parties à la conciliation
prévue à l'article L 1411 vaut nullité
de la
procédure cet amendement me semble être
un amendement de bon sens la procédure
de conciliation devant être le fruit
d'un accord et d'un dialogue entre deux
parties prenantes au litige l'absence
d'une des deux parties ne peut aboutir à
un résultat je rappelle que cet
amendement se réfère à l'article 14111
qui prévoit que le Conseil des prudomes
règle par voie de conciliation les
différents qui peuvent s'élever à
l'occasion de tout contrat de travail
soumis aux dispositions du présent code
entre les employeurs ou leurs
représentants et les salariés qu'ils
emploient ils jugent les litiges lorsque
la conciliation n'a pas abouti la
procédure de conciliation ne peut être
mise en œuvre si les deux parties
prenantes ne sont pas inves dans la
procédure nous voulons donc revoir
l'alinéa 3 de l'article 16 par cet
amendement merci chers collègues je vais
demander l'avis de notre rapporteur sur
ces deux amendements en discussion
commune
oui merci madame la Présidente sur
l'amendement
623 qui vise à supprimer la notion
d'indemnité forfaitaire en fait cette
indemnité sera fixée d'un commun accord
entre les parties et pour apprendre
comme élément de comparaison les règles
prévues dans le code du travail par
exemple 6 mois minimum d'indemnité en
cas de licenciement sans cause réelle et
sérieuse donc je crois que cette cette
clause trouve toute sa justification
donc
défavorable l'amendement
610 vous voulez porter en principe la
nullité de la procédure de la
conciliation en cas d'absence de l'une
des parties à la iation je crois qu'il
serait sage d'attendre les conclusions
du rapport que nous avons demandé au
gouvernement je je vous renvoie à
l'article 16 bis du du projet de loi
nous avions suggéré à la suite d'un
amendement du CRC qui a été adopté en
commission qu'un que le gouvernement
puisse nous proposer un rapport sur les
conditions d'accès à la justice
prudomale 6 mois après la promulgation
de la loi de façon à avoir assez vite un
aperçu sur les conditions de mise en
œuvre de cette disposition donc
défavorable très bien je vous remercie
vote réservé sur ces amendements une
série d'amendements encore en discussion
commune madame Laborde le 557 rectifié
et je défendrai en même temps le 557
rectifié et le 558 rectifié très bien
merci supprimer les alinéas régissant
les délais de prescription de l'action
en justice l'article 16 touche à un
sujet extrêmement délicat vous prévoyez
de réduire les délais de prescription de
5 à 2 ans pour toute action née de
l'exécution ou de la rupture du contrat
et de 5 à 3 ans pour l'action en
paiement de salaire nous le savons bien
ces dispositions font partie du fameux
donnant donnant et ont été imposé par le
patronat en échange de dispositions plus
favorables pour les salariés nous ne
pouvons nous ne pouvons toutefois pas
cautionner une telle régression avant
2008 les délais de prescription étaient
de 30 ans ils ont été réduit à 5 ans
sous l'ancien quinquena et aujourd'hui
vous nous demandez d'aller encore plus
loin au détriment des salariés nous ne
pouvons pas accepter ce qui s'apparente
à une véritable régression pour les
droits des salariés c'est la raison pour
laquelle vous nous nous vous proposons
de supprimer les alénéas 9 à 15 pour
conserver les délais de prescription
actuel c'est-à-dire 5 ans je vous
remercie
merci Madame Laborde pour la
présentation de ces deux amendements le
611 rectifié monsieur de cessard et puis
le 615 si vous
voulez les de je n'ai plus d'espace de
respiration entre deux merci chers
collègu vous l'avez compris madame la
Présidente c'est cet amendement
ressemble beaucoup à celui de défendu
par ma collègue du groupe radical de
gauche cet amendement vise à revenir au
régime de prescription antérieure
c'est-à-dire un délai de 5 ans une
réduction des délais de prescription tel
que prévu par le projet de loi à 2 ans
n'est pas justifié porte atteinte au
droit des salariés rende des compte 2
ans un délai de prescription c'est c'est
presque rien quoi c'est voilà je ne vois
pas pour enfin comprend c'est
une voilà je n'insisterai pas sur les
arguments puisqu'ils ont été développés
par ma collègue merci sur le
615 je supprime l'alinéa
15 cet amendement vise à rétablir les
délais de prescription d'action en
paiement ou en répétition du salaire à 5
ans une réduction des délais de
prescription telle que prévu par le
projet de loi à 3 ans n'est pas justifié
porte atteinte au droits des salariés
alors là faudra vraiment vraiment faire
preuve de beaucoup d'imagination
monsieur le ministre pour me prouver que
c'est un droit nouveau et qui améliore
la condition des
salariés merci chers collègues l'avis de
notre rapporteur sur ces quatre
amendements dont deux identiques
oui j'apporterai madame la Présidente si
si vous le permettez une réponse globale
à l'ensemble de ces amendements qui sont
évidemment de de même nature le délai de
prescription de de ces action est en
effet significativement diminuée je
ferai trois réponses de de naturees
différentes la première pour dire qu'en
effet mais vous l'avez vous-même
souligné cette disposition s'inscrit
dans un cadre d'équilibre global et elle
participe à cet équilibre global dans
l'accord qu'on pu trouver les
partenaires sociaux deuxième observation
une très grande partie des contentieux
est en fait traité dans les 2 ans je
crois que c'est l'étude de de la réalité
qui qui qui nous le l'apporte et puis
troisième élément certes objectivement
je conviens avec vous que c'est un
retrait du droit au profit des salariés
mais en même temps je crois qu'il faut
aussi se réjouir du fait que l'action
contentieuse en direction des des
salariés pardon de la part des salariés
ne doit pas durer trop longtemps il faut
aussi que les pages puissent se tourner
pour permettre de passer à autre chose
donc je pense aussi que cette
disposition n'a pas que des vertus
négatives pour toutes ces raisons
j'apporte un avis défavorable
merci merci vote réservé sur ces
amendements ainsi que sur l'article 16
nous arrivons aux 16 bis nouveau vote
réservé nous arrivons à l'article
17 l'amendement 612 rectifié monsieur de
cessar
c'est deux amendements en discussion
commune concne c'est mon
dernier notre amendement revient sur la
mise en place des instances
représentatives du personnel il
s'établit en deux temps d'une part nous
voulons raccourcir le délai entre la
mise en place du comité d'entreprise et
l'effec iité de ses attributions de 1 an
à 6 mois dans le texte on dit il peut se
mettre en place pendant 1 an nous on dit
il faut 6 mois peut mettre en route au
bout de 6 mois la durée de 1 an retenue
dans le texte de loi est trop longue
pendant 1 an le comité d'entreprise sera
élu mais ne pourra pas exercer son
mandat donc cet amendement dans sa
première partie vise à donner un délai
raisonnable de 6 mois à l'employeur pour
qu'il puisse se conformer aux
obligations d'information et de
consultation de du comité
d'entreprise 2è partie de l'amendement
par ailleurs il nous semble primordial
de mettre en place un office
parlementaire sur ce point monsieur le
ministre vous n'avez cessé de prenner
plus de démocratie sociale et répéter
qu'il fallait faire confiance aux
partenaires sociaux pour autant les
parlementaires ne peuvent être exclus de
cette démarche malgré les procédures qui
sont mises en œuvre pour
nous qui nous empêche d'amender ce texte
la mise en œuvre de la démocratie
sociale que nous conagion par ailleurs
doit pouvoir être suivi par les
parlementaires qui pourront ainsi juger
et informer des impacts de la présente
loi sur l'évolution du rapport de force
auquel mon honteux entre les partenaires
sociaux notamment au niveau de
l'entreprise nous nous inquiétons en
particulier que le mdeef notamment
refuse désormais toute négociation dans
les entreprises se targant d'avoir fait
assez de compromis avec Laan cet AM cet
amendement vise donc dans sa deuxème
partie la création d'un office
parlementaire de l'évolution de la
qualité de la démocratie sociale je
répète cet amendement vise donc parce
que il je suppose qu'il n'est pas retenu
donc peut-être qu'il peut y avoir un
engagement du ministre c'est C
amendement vise donc et souhaite la
création d'un office parlementaire de
l'évolution de la qualité de la
démocratie
sociale merci chers collègues le 559
rectifié madame Laborde alors cet
amendement est identique à la première
partie de l'amendement de notre collègue
de César c'est-à-dire que il concerne
notre étonnement à la nécessité d'un
délai d'un an pour mettre en place des
procédures d'information et de
consultation et ça ne nous semble pas
justifié merci Madame Laborde je vais
donc demander à notre rapporteur l'avis
l'avis de la commission sur ces deux
amendements merci madame la Présidente
je voudrais sur le premier amendement
euh apporter une information aussi
précise que possible parce que cet
amendement n'a pas été examiné en l'état
par la commission il a été corrigé
depuis et en commission il ne portait
que sur la première partie de cet
amendement c'est-à-dire sur la réduction
de la période de tolérance accordée à
l'employeur et sur ce point la
commission euh avait donné un avis
défavorable la seconde partie a été
introduite postérieurement je ne vous en
fais pas reproche mais je ne peux donc
pas par rapport à cette initiative je
parle de la création d'un office
parlementaire de l'évolution de la
qualité de la démocratie sociale je ne
peux pas strict au sininsu apporter
l'avis de la commission puisqu'elle n'a
pas été consultée sur ce point mais sur
le premier point c'est un avis
défavorable
merci euh sur le 559
également je vous écoute quand même
monsieur rapporteur diminution de 12 à 6
mois du délai pour se conformer
complètement aux obligations récurrentes
d'information du du comité
d'entreprise nous sommes là dans
l'équilibre de l'accord c'est donc un
avis défavorable merci Monsieur le
Ministre merci merci le vote est réservé
ainsi que pour la minist
ainsi que pour l'article
17 nous arrivons mes chers collègues à
l'article 18 madame rugière le 523
rectifi madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues l'article 18
prévoit l'expérimentation du CDI
intermittent dans des entreprises de
moins de 50 salariés et dans des
secteurs bien définis cette
expérimentation doit être ouverte au
secteur de commerce du Commerce de
détail de l'abem des articles textiles
en effet ce secteur subit de fortes
variation d'activité en raison des
saisons des modes de consommation et de
la localisation géographique de nombreux
commerces situés en zones touristiques
littoral montagne ville historiqu et
cetera environ 11 % des salariés du
secteur soit plus de 9000 salariés
travaillent dans une boutique située en
zone touristique et 27 % des employeurs
de la branche déclare reconnaître une
alternance de période travaillé et non
travaillé de plus le secteur du commerce
de détail de l'habillement est proche du
secteur de commerce des articles de
sport et des équipements de loisirs les
deux secteurs mettent à disposition la
même cl de la même clientèle ses
saisonnière ou touristique des articles
similaires habillement ou sport destinés
à faciliter son accueil ou ses activités
de détente et de loisir grâce à cette
expérimentation les magasins ayant une
activité intermittente pourront recruter
des salariés en CDI avec l'ensemble de
garantie correspondante à la place du
CDD saisonnier plus précaire de plus le
CDI intermittent est le seul moyen légal
d'emboche quand le recours au CDD
saisonniers est impossible par exemple
lorsque chaque année le salarié
travaille pendant toute la période
d'activité saisonnière bien sûr du
magasin qu'à des magasins bien sûr qui
sont fermés pendant les mois d'année de
l'année en l'absence de de fréquentation
touristique et je sais ce dont je parle
puisque je suis dans une zone
touristique cet amendement vise donc à
étendre l'expérimentation du CDI
intermittant au commerce de détail de
l'habillement et des articles textiles
il renvoie donc à un décret la
détermination des secteurs qui sont visé
par cet article merci madame la
Présidente chers collègues l'avis de la
commission sur l'amendement présenté par
Madame
Brugier merci madame la Présidente mes
chers collègues l'article 18 propose une
expérimentation du CDI intermittent dans
trois secteurs d'activité vous proposez
d'étendre ces secteurs un 4è qui serait
un autre secteur expérimental on peut en
comprendre et et en approuver les
raisons mais les signataires ont
souhaité se limiter pour l'instant à
trois secteurs puisque nous sommes dans
un cadre expérimental il convient
d'attendre 2014 pour connaître les
premiers résultats de cette
expérimentation il sera temps à ce
moment-là d'en imaginer l'extension le
cas échéant pour l'instant
défavorable merci Monsieur le Ministre
même avis merci sur cet amendement et
sur l'article 18 le vote est réservé sur
l'article 19 également après l'article
19 je suis saisie d'un amendement 554
rectifié présenté par Madame Laborde
merci madame la Présidente par cet
amendement nous souhaitons que les
dispositions du projet de loi puissent
s'appliquer aux salariés des Chambre
d'Agriculture aussi les est proposé
d'insérer de nouveaux alinéas à
l'article L 5144 du code
rural merci Madame La Borde votre avis
monsieur
le monsieur jeaner sur cet amendement
554 rectifié sachant que c'est le
dernier am endement à
l'examen merci madame la Présidente sur
la base des informations qui qui me sont
communiqués cet amendement est
satisfait merci monsieur le ministre
c'est un amendement qui a été satisfait
par l'introduction par le rapporteur en
commission de disposition qui
correspondent à celui-ci donc il peut
peut pourrait être retiré sans dommage
pour lui-même au contraire merci
Monsieur le Ministre vote réserv V sur
cet amendement sur l'article 19 bis
nouveau également sur l'article 20
également monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues en application de l'article 44
derniè alinéa de la Constitution et de
l'article 42 alinéa 7 du Règlement le
gouvernement demande au Sénat de se
prononcer par un seul vote sur les
articles 5 à 20 modifié par les
amendements proposés ou acceptés par le
gouvernement et l'ensemble du projet de
loi voici la liste des amendement
proposés ou acceptés par le gouvernement
le 556 rectifié le 642 le 661 le 644 le
663 le 660 le
646 le
647 le
662 le 648 et le
6499 rectifié à l'article 5 à l'article
8 le 664 et le
665 à l'article 8 bis le 529 rectifié à
l'article 9 le
678 et le
67 19 à l'article 10 le
666 à l'article 12 le
667 et le
264 à l'article 13 le
672 le
668 le
673 et le
671 je mets au voix les articles 5 à 20
modifiés par les amendements proposés ou
acceptés par le gouvernement et
l'ensemble du projet de loi j'ai déjà
des inscriptions pour les explications
de
vote madame
marinoelinman madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre mes chers collègues
je voterai contre cet accord parce que
je le trouve
déséquilibré le débat parlementaire n'a
pas modifié la donne et donc mon avis
n'a pas changé non plus je l'ai rappelé
à l'Assemblée nationale 41
parlementaires socialistes n'ont pas
approuvé cet accord 6 ont voté contre 31
ou 32 peut-être 52 il y a eu une
contestation d'une voix se sont abstenus
des avancées intéressantes étaient
prévues
elles auraient mérité d'être consolidées
et le débat parlementaire ne l'a pas
permis l'élargissement des assurances
complémentaires sont en fait très peu
payé par le patronat par les entreprises
les droits rechargeables qui on nous
annonce pour les les droits au chômage
sont soumis aux alléat financiers du
futur accord unéit
la taxation des CDD est très limitée
dans sa portée est très faible dans son
ampleur de sorte qu'on peut craindre que
son efficacité soit assez
limitée la les représentants des
salariés dans les conseils
d'administration sont un vrai progrès
mais les seuils qui sont retenus sont
bien inférieurs au rapport Galois et
j'espère d'ailleurs que ça ne conclut
pas le sujet car il me semble semble que
il ne faudrait pas que ça fasse
jurisprudence et qu'on dise puisque
désormais la ni a fixé le nombre de
salariés dans les conseils
d'administration il revient à la
négociation sociale d'en définir le
cadre alors que sur ce point particulier
plus encore que sur d'autres s'agissant
du pouvoir reconnu au partis dans
l'entreprise à savoir le pouvoir des
salariés je ne pense pas que l'accord du
Medef soit un élément du meddeef ou
d'autres d'ailleurs soit un élément
déterminant il s'agit d'un d'un
équilibre des pouvoirs démocratiques et
ça devrait être de la loi pur
sucre mais c'est insuffisance ne
justifierait pas un vote contre si en
face je n'avais pas le sentiment qu'il y
a pour le moins des reculs et pour ne
pas blesser les signataires de l'accord
pour dire au moins des
menaces
d'abord l'accord de maintien dans
l'emploi même les journaux économiques
les plus bienveillants en direction des
signataires de l'accord
ou même en direction de la gauche
considère quand même que cet accord ne
sont pas très différents des fameux
accords compétitivité qui avaiit été
présenté par le candidat Nicolas Sarkozi
et en tout cas il constitue une brèche
inquiétante pourquoi parce qu'il met en
cause la supériorité du du contrat de
travail sur des accords il met en cause
la supériorité du contrat de travail
donc les libertés contractuelles par
rapport à des accords
collectif et par ailleurs puisqu'il n'a
pas été accepté le principe que quand 10
salariés refuse l'accord il bénéficie
d'un plan social d'entreprise pour eux
ça sera un
recul par ailleurs l'effort demandé aux
actionnaires l'effort demandé aux
dirigeants est très hypothétique très
flou tandis que les efforts demandés aux
salariés sont sonnants et
trébuchants
enfin les conditions des licenciements
économiques de mon point de vue sont
pour le moins
assoupli je ne vais pas reprendre un
détail technique un débat technique qui
a eu lieu d'ailleurs à l'Assemblée sur
de faites l'affaiblissement du recours
aux
juges mais surtout mais surtout et là il
ne s'agit pas simplement d'une affaire
d'une affaire sociale mais bien de la
défense de notre capacité productive
dans ce pays des défenses de l'industrie
dans notre
pays ne pas mettre en œuvre un système
qui permet de limiter les licenciement
économique
abusif par la voie judiciaire est une
fragilité majeure parce que aujourd'hui
nous l'avons bien vu les licenciements
économiques non fondés ou fondé sur un
seul impératif boursier qui sont quand
même dans bien des cas la cause de la
désindustrialisation de certains P de
notre économie non'ont pas aujourd'hui
les outils permettant les de limiter les
abus nous avions voté en tout cas les
socialistes les écologistes
et le groupe CRC un projet de loi avant
les élections
présidentielles ce projet de loi était
fondé sur justement la reconnaissance du
motif économique mieux défini le recours
au juges et un référé auprès du juge
pour permettre de vérifier que ce motif
est bien fondé économiquement et pouvoir
arrêter l'horrible spirale qui fait
qu'une fois que c'est engagé l'usine
ferme même quand les salariés ont gagné
le temps est compté je terminerai
j'espère me tromper j'espère pouvoir
vérifier que mon pessimisme et les
inquiétudes ne seront pas confirmées
mais je vous le dis tout net alors que
nos concitoyens attendaient une grande
loi contre le licenciement économique et
la reprise une grande loi contre la
précarité ils n'auront eu ni les lois
des congets payés ni les lois des 35h
des 39h ni la 5e semaine des congets
payés ils attendent de la gauche une
grande loi fondatrice et pas simplement
la ratification d'un accord qui pour ma
part je le crois est déséquilibré et en
tout cas n'est pas la hauteur de la
situation merci chers
collègues la parole est à Madame Goulet
ou madame le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues ch madame
assassie je voudrais en quelques mots
revenir sur les conditions qui ont
présidé à ce à ce débat lundi dernier à
la même place j'ai fait un rappel au
règlement pour attirer l'attention du
Sénat et du ministre en charge des
relations avec le Parlement sur l'aspect
pour le moins chaotique dans l'EMP du
temps de la semaine puisque nous avons
siégé lundi sur le texes sur les
collectivités locales puis à la suite
d'un changement de dernière minute nous
n'avons pas siégé mardi pour commencer
ce texte que chacun sa savait comme
important mercredi dans des conditions
difficiles euh l'importance du de ce
texte et le nombre d'amendements
présentés et proposés euh marquait
évidemment un incident prévisible c'est
de toute façon ce qui s'est pardon non
non enfin un incident de séance suivit
de d'autres incidents mais en tous les
cas il était évident que ce texte allait
être un texte chargé qui nécessiterit en
toute hypothèse plus de temps pour être
réglé dans dans des conditions donc
puisque nous sommes en matière de de
droit social je dirais que la situation
comporte une initiative et une
imputabilité si le gouvernement a pris
l'initiative de ce vote bloqué
l'imputabilité est probablement à à
rechercher ailleurs et je voulais vous
dire Madame assassie tout à l'heure que
l'après-midi pour nous nous a semblé
bien longue pour vous aussi probablement
parce que ce ce monologue n'est pas la
façon dont nous pouvons concevoir un
texte aussi important qui n'est
finalement que la transcription d'un
accord et finalement qu'on aurait pu
imaginer pouvoir le discuter en tous les
cas de façon un peu plus apaisée dans un
climat qui n'était pas celui de la la
lutte des classes que cherchait
précisément cet accord à gommé et que
nous n'avons pas eu aujourd'hui je
voulais vous dire que nous le
regrettions absolument que ce vote
bloqué n'est pas n'est pas une pratique
qu'il devait répondre probablement à des
difficultés dont nous ne sommes pas
responsables euh quand toute hypothèse
nous nous considérons que que ce texte
constitue une avancée à certains à
certains égards que nous que nous le
voterons mais que néanmoins en ce qui
concerne la procédure et surtout une
procédure
itérative de difficultés d'emploi du
temps et d'ordre du jour dans cette
maison j'espère que ce sera la dernière
fois que nous aurons ce type d'incident
encore une fois totalement prévisible je
vous remercie merci chers collègues la
parole est à Monsieur van
lurenberg merci madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues je ne reviendrai
pas sauf cursivement sur ce que vient de
rappeler ma collègue Nathalie Goulet sur
cette procédure de vote
bloqué les responsabilités sont
clairement partagées celles du
gouvernement je n'y reviendrai pas mais
celle aussi du groupe SRC qui a joué à
l'apprenti sorcier et nous a privé d'un
débat clair nourri sur un texte
essentiel essentiel pour la démocratie
et le fonctionnement économique de notre
pays mais il est clair que ce texte a
permis de mettre en lumière un problème
de
fond nous venons d'assister au Sénat à
une rupture spectaculaire entre le PC et
le PS entre la gauche de la gauche et
l'autre
gauche sur un texte essentiel pas
anodin c'est donc symbolique et ça
démontre à l'envie s'il était nécessaire
qu'il y a deux lectures diamétralement
opposé de la démocratie et du dialogue
social l'une marxiste de lutte de
classes et l'autre social
démocrate vous parlerez à votre lors de
votre temp on est en droit de se
demander si la majorité est encore en
mesure d'avancer de cette façon
chaotique et de gouverner sans
clarification de sa ligne politique et
en tous les cas nous pensons que les
Français ont le droit de savoir nonsant
au
texte il marque des progrès sociaux
incontestables et il faut saluer les
sign tous les signataires de l'accord
national interprofessionnel qui nous ont
permis d'avancer nous avons cherché à
transposer de façon loyale pour notre
part et respectueuse ce texte en terme
législatif
convenez-en même si quelques amendements
nous ont été refusés qui privent
peut-être le texte de certaines
précisions utiles monsieur le ministre
il y en a il y a en a tout de même
suffisamment je dirais dans ce texte
pour nous
réjouir de son
intérêt par exemple la complémentaire
santé des amendements de
transparence
corrigés bien sûr mais néanmoins qui
permettent certainement de clarifier la
situation sur le choix des
opérateurs le contrat personnel de
formation
qui est un progrès pour moi
essentiel pour l'avenir des entreprises
de notre pays
ensuite comme les droits d'ailleurs
aussi rechargeables pour les
chômeurs l'avancée pour la démocratie et
la part que représente la
participation avec bien sûr
d'administrateurs dans les conseils
d'administration et les conseils de
surveillance de l'entreprise mais aussi
la consult
du CE du comité d'entreprise sur la
stratégie de
l'entreprise je r Je reconnais aussi que
il y a un effort de fait que nous avons
essayé de traduire qui me paraît encore
un peu
insuffisant sur le recul des contrats
courts nous sommes vraiment favorables à
un contrat à durée indéterminée à droit
progressif tout en respectant
effectivement les nécessités d'une
souplesse mais je crois qu'il y a des
abus auxquels il faudra remédier et je
doute que le texte soit suffisant sur ce
point mais c'est un
progrès sur le temps partiel bien
entendu monsieur le ministre vous avez
apaisé nos craintes vous avez précisé
que dans les secteurs médicauxsociaux et
du service à la personne vous serez
vigilant et que vous serez attentif au
respect de l'accord mais aussi à la mise
en œuvre à la possibilité de mise en
œuvre nous serons aussi très vigilants
et nous nous donnons rendez-vous si j'ai
bien compris en
2014 que
dire du cœur du
texte il me paraît
équilibré maintien dans l'emploi la
mobilité interne l'encadrement des
licenciement collectif et le
reclassement apporte certes un cont
stablement plus de souplesse aux
entreprises mais aussi en contrepartie
on vient de les
évoquer des droits nouveaux pour les
salariés et c'est cela qui me paraît
évidemment
fondamental nous attendons beaucoup de
de ce texte qui marque justement un
tournant un
tournant remarquable fondamental dans
les relations sociales en France la
France rejoint enfin le camp des
démocraties nordiques qui ont
inspiré avec succès
reconnaissons-le la Flex cette Flexi
sécurité à la
française je dis avec succès parce que
chez eux on envoit les résultats
incontestablement en terme de
chômage l'esprit de l'accord national
interprofessionnel correspond à la
philosophie de la ocratie sociale du
dialogue social qui inspire la politique
de notre groupe et qui est l'émanation
je l'ai dit des formations politiqu
centriste et démocrate social depuis les
lendemains de la guerre c'est la
première raison qui entraîne notre vote
positif le vote positif de notre groupe
mais dans ce contexte économique
dépressif je ne sais pas si ce texte
permettra de créer des emplois mais
j'espère vivement qu'il permettra d'en
sauver et c'est la seconde raison pour
la
évidemment nous voterons ce texte merci
chers collègues la parole s' vous
permettez pour terminer complètement
vous apprécierez monsieur le ministre et
chers collègues que nous savons dépasser
les querelles partisane pour approuver
ce qui nous paraît essentiel à l'avenir
de notre pays et de notre économie merci
chers
collègue la parole est à Monsieur
verin
il y a un an avec des millions de
salariés nous appelions à battre Nicolas
Sarkozi pour permettre l'émergence d'une
politique radicalement différente nous
portions l'espoir avec des millions de
Françaises et de français que les
aspirations populaires soient enfin
entendues et que l'humain prime sur la
finance celle-ci doit être en effet au
service de la société et non l'inverse
nous voulions que collectivement on
redonne des droits à ceux qui depuis des
années n'en avaient plus ce soir il
aurait pu y avoir une majorité de gauche
pour changer la donne il n'y a pas eu
débat réel sur nos propositions en
faisant le choix de transposer un accord
voulu négocié exclusivement dans les
locaux du meddeef écrit par lui vous
avez cédé monsieur le ministre à toutes
ses exigences y compris cell
inconstitutionnelles et non conforme à
nos engagements internationaux et
européen vous avez bradé le code du
travail et les droits des salariés
malgré un examen attentif nous
condivisant à déposer près de 450
amendements nous n'avons trouvé aucun
droit réel supplémentaire susceptible de
nous amener à voter en faveur de ce
projet de loi je n'évoquerai que
quelques points la généralisation de la
complémentaire santé nous y voyons
d'abord pour notre part le renoncement à
renforcer la sécurité sociale pire pour
offrir aux assurances privées commercial
un marché de plus de 4 milliards d'euros
vous privez la sécurité sociale de 2
milliards d'euros alors que vous vous
apprêtez à réduire les allocations
familiales dans le seul but de faire des
économie de la même manière vous
réduisez les droits des salariés en
autorisant les employeurs à réduire leur
rémunération jusqu'à 1,2 SMIG et à
flexibiliser l'organisation du travail
jamais un gouvernement de droite n'a osé
prendre une telle mesure Nicolas Sarkozi
avait bien imaginé les accords
compétitivité emploi mais c'est vous qui
les transposé aujourd'hui dans la loi en
vérité tout a été fait pour anesthésier
le débat pour détourner les salariés des
véritables enjeux de ce texte désormais
ceux-ci seront complètement désarmés
face à leur employeurs lorsque ces
derniers ne leur laisseront qu'un choix
se soumettre à la modification
autoritaire de leur contrat de travail
ou se faire licencier un licenciement
individuel pour motif économique nous
ditons à ceci près que ni l'autorité
administrative ni les juges ne pourront
vérifier la réalité du motif économique
invoqué par l'employeur le MDEF n'avait
qu'un rêve pouvoir licencier sans motif
et sans indemnité et de plus rapidement
grâce à vous des millions de salariés
subiront l'application de ces nouveaux
dispositifs
régressif il n'oublieront pas que c'est
un gouvernement socialiste qui a rendu
cela possible alors même que vous aviez
les moyens de sécuriser l'emploi et de
relancer l'économie vous pouviez
notamment vous appuyer sur la volonté
commune de la gauche au Sénat
d'interdire les licenciements boursiers
quant aux femmes elles seront encore les
grandes perdantes elles savent
contrairement ce qui est affirmé que la
durée minimum obligatoire de 24 he ne
sera que théorique elles savent
contrairement à ce qui est prétendu
qu'elles ne gagneront pas plus demain à
cause de la possibilité que vous offrez
au patron de conclure h avenant dans
l'avé dans l'année cela aura tout
simplement pour effet de repousser le
moment à partir duquel le paiement des
heures complémentaire se déclenchera
pour tout dire monsieur le ministre
laisser la possibilité à des accords de
branche de ramener la rémunération des
heures complémentaires de 25 à 10 % et
particulièrement cynique et totalement
in acceptable nous savons aussi madame
la rapporteur de la délégation au droits
des femmes l'a reconnu elle-même que les
dispositions contenues dans l'article 8
ne les aideront en rien à concilier vie
professionnelle et vie familiale
certaines mesures mêmees accentueront
les discrimination je ne reviens pas sur
les débats que nous avons eu sur la
mobilité volontaire sécurisée sur les
droits rechargeables à l'assurance
chômage droit théorique s'il en est ni
sur les faibles et relatives avancés qui
sont accordés au représent ent des
salariés les comités d'entreprise
pourront certes se prononcer sur le plan
stratégique de l'entreprise mais au
final laavis des représentants du
personnel n'y changera rien vous avez
conçu ce projet pour que le patronnat
reste seul maître à bord alors que nous
proposions pour notre part la création
d'un droit de véau suspentif de manière
à permettre au représentants des
salariés de construire des projets
alternatifs et viables capables de
préserver l'emploi c'est une loi de
sécurisation de l'emploi que les
salariés et les citoyens attendaient
c'est une loi de flexibilisation du
travail et de sécurisation des
licenciements que vous proposez après
être resté sourd à l'opposition du
premier du 3e syndicat de France et aux
450 amendements que nous avons déposé
mais j'ai pu constater en suivant les
travaux de ce soir que vous étiez plus
enclin à répondre aux quelques
parlementaires de droit restés dans
l'hémicycle plutôt ô qu'X propositions
présentées par le groupe communiste et
élaboré en association avec le monde du
travail c'est pour cela que le groupe
CRC votera contre
ce merci chers collègues la parole est à
Monsieur
Cambon madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre les conditions du vote qui va
intervenir dans quelques instants
resteront sûrement comme un moment
particulièrement sombre de l'histoire de
notre institution
au moment où le chômage s'accroit de
près de 1000 chômeurs par jour où tant
d'entreprises d'usines d'exploitations
agricoles sont dans les difficultés ù
cessent leurs activités du fait de
conjuguer de la crise économique et des
mesures négatif que vous prenez vous
avez proposé un texte issu de la
négociation des parlementaires des
partenaires sociaux dont l'importance
n'avait échappé à personne en permettant
plus de flexibilité aux entreprises dans
la gestion quotidienne de leurs
effectifs et en apportant en
contrepartie plus de sécurité aux
salariés vous aviez une occasion unique
de donner enfin un commencement de
réponse aux difficultés auxquelles
entreprises et salariés sont confrontés
du fait de la crise encore fallait-il
donner au temps du débat parlementaire
toute l'importance qu'il
nécessitait sur ce sujet essentiel vous
aviez le devoir et même l'impérieuse
nécessité de laisser chaque groupe
s'exprimer et traduire par des votes
successifs les amendements qu'il
souhaitait apporter à votre texte c'est
la loi de la démocratie c'est l'essence
même de l'existence du Parlement que de
pouvoir y discuter contredire s'opposer
amender les projets de l'exécutif or
vous qui pendant tant d'années n'avez eu
de cess de nous donner des leçons à ce
sujet vous qui nous avez si souvent
reproché à tort d'avoir bafoué les
droits du Parlement vous n'hésitez pas à
organiser un véritable coup de force
contre l'une des composantes de votre
majorité présidentielle et ce quelques
dizaines d'heures seulement après le
début de la discussion nous ne
partageons pas tout le monde le sait les
positions de nos collègues communistes
et républicains et nous combattons
régulièrement les caricatures qu'ils
donnent des chefs d'entreprisees de leur
motivation et de leur
nous partageons néanmoins avec eux la
volonté de voir respecter les droits du
Parlement cet article
443 utilisé une seule fois par
l'ancienne majorité au terme de plus de
3 semaines de débat relatif à la réforme
des retraites cet article est vous le
savez une arme atomique à la disposition
du gouvernement pour faire taire le
Parlement vous avez cru devoir
l'utiliser alors qu'un tel sujet ncess
CIT tout autant que le mariage pour tous
la confrontation des idées la discussion
des amendements nous aurions dû du reste
comprendre vos intentions dès le départ
de cette discussion nous avons eu une
seule satisfaction elle est ce soir
d'importance à l'article 1 nous avons
réussi à rétablir la liberté de choix
des entreprises pour leur complémentaire
santé comme le prévoyit du reste
l'accord signé par les partenaires
sociaux hélas vous avez immédiatement
brandit l'arme de la deuxième
délibération pour nous remettre au pas
ce soir alors même que vous ne cessz
d'appeler à la moralisation de la vie
publique vous donnez du Sénat l'image
d'un théâtre d'ombre qui dégrade l'image
du Parlement et des parlementaires qui
ont travaillé ce projet de loi et même
si leurs opinions ne vous conviennent
pas même si le calendrier allait à
l'encontre de vos prévisions vous
n'aviez pas le droit moral d'utiliser
une telle procédure le résultat vous le
connaîtrez bien vite d'un projet de loi
qui pouvait apporter des éléments
importants de solution pour dynamiser le
monde économique en pleine crise tout en
renforçant le droit des salariés vous
avez organisé un simulacre de démocratie
imposant à vous seul avec le soutien de
vos collègues socialistes un texte qui
aurait pu être le fruit d'un consensus
non seulement beaucoup plus large mais
aussi sûrement beaucoup plus efficace
alors enfermez-vous dans vos certitudes
privilégiez les longs débats sur les
modes de scrutin c'est certainement ce
qui va passionner les Français et régler
une part de leurs difficultés ces
Français ils portent déjà un jugement
sans appel sur votre capacité à nous
sortir de la crise ces Français une fois
de plus apprécieront vos méthodes ne
vous étonnez pas dès lors que les débats
tronqués au Parlement se déplace dans la
rue avec les débordements que nous
regrettons et que nous condamnons ce
soir le groupe UMP s'abstiendra sur ce
texte mais condamne fermement l'atteinte
particulièrement grave que vous venez de
porter au droit du Parlement merci
Monsieur Cambon la parole est à Madame
Laborde madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègu je tenais
avant tout à remercier chaleureusement
le ministre pour son écoute et le
rapporteur pour son excellent travail
je ne reviendrai pas sur le climat un
peu tendu de nos débats mais je redirai
simplement ce que j'ai déjà expliqué
lors de la discussion générale mes chers
collègues vous le savez notre pays
traverse une crise économique et sociale
particulièrement grave qui se tradu par
une destruction d'emploi une hausse
constante du chômage et une plus grande
précarité les Français sont de plus en
plus inquiets pour leur avenir c'est
pourquoi dès la conférence sociale de
juillet dernier le Premier ministre a
fait du combat pour l'emploi sa Pr
priorité et a proposé aux partenaires
sociaux d'entamer une négociation sur
l'amélioration de la sécurisation de
l'emploi qui a quand même duré 4 mois
marqué par la recherche d'un compromis
les partenaires sociaux se sont entendus
sur un accord majoritaire ce projet de
loi en est l'aboutissement peut-être pas
tout à fait satisfaisant mais lequel le
texte auquel nous sommes parvenus est
équilibré l'enjeu est de permettre aux
entreprises de s'adapter aux mutations
économiques et de créer de nouveaux
droits pour les salariés je pense en
particulier à la généralisation de la
couverture complémentaire santé au
droits rechargeable à l'assurant chômage
à la taxation des contr contrats court à
l'ouverture des conseils
d'administration au salariés ou au
comptes personnels de
formation bien sûr je regrette que
beaucoup de nos amendements aent reçu un
avis défavorable alors qu'ils allaient
dans le sens d'une meilleure protection
des salariés en revanche je me félicite
que vous ayez donné cet après-midi un
avis favorable à notre amendement qui
prévoit que le nombre de salariés dans
les conseils d'administration n'est qu'à
panché ce texte participera j'en suis
sûr à la réussite de la politique mise
en œuvre par votre gouvernement en
faveur de la croissance et de l'emploi
et pour toutes ces raisons les radicau
de gauche et la majorité du groupe RDSE
vous apporteront leur soutien je vous
remercie merci chers collègues la parole
est à Jean de
cessard et oui madame la Présidente et
tout
d'abord comment ne pas commencer cette
intervention sans déplorer l'atmosphère
générale de la discussion sur ce projet
de loi et l'utilisation par le
gouvernement du vote bloqué on ne peut
pas d'un côté faire l'apologie de la
démocratie social et de l'autre déigner
d'une telle façon le travail
parlementaire les conditions dans
lequelles nous avons étudié ce projet de
loi pose la question quel est le rôle
des parlementaires alors bien sûr je
comprend la volonté du gouvernement de
vouloir prendre des mesures d'urgence
afin de répondre à une situation
particulièrement tendue sur le front de
l'emploi et nous tous à gauche nous
écologistes en tant que partenairire de
gouvernement nous nous associer à cette
à cet objectif et de manière active
partoutù nous sommes présents cette
lutte quotidienne contre la précarité et
le chômage de masse mais quand même
monsieur le ministre on aurait pu
prendre un peu plus de temps pour
discuter on aurait pu quand même prendre
le temps nécessaire de débattre
hein nous nous avons déposé sans forcer
60 amendements alors vous pouvez nous
dire c'est trop vous avez pas d déposer
60 amendements 60 amendement peut-être
que il y en a deux ou trois que j'aurais
pu regretter d'avoir déposé qu'on
j'aurais pu enlever mais tout le reste
posait de vraies questions
donc on a déposé des sur l'aménagement
des droits nouveaux sur le modèle
d'accès à la santé sur l'intégration de
la dimension environnementale du monde
de l'entreprise
mais je regrette que la stratégie du
vote bloqué ne nous a pas permis de
débattre réellement
sereinement de ces de ces amendements de
nos amendements et de tous les
amendements sur le fond
jaacte que le projet de loi garantit
certaines avancées généralisation de la
complémentaire santé compte personnel de
la formation mobilité externe
proposition contre le trava temps
partiel subi incitation au CDI pour les
jeunes de moins de 26 ans droit
rechargeable pour l'assurance chômage
mais la question posée au-delà de ces
droits nouveaux affirmés dans le projet
de loi est de définir leur modalité de
mise en œuvre comme je l'ai souigné
comme je l'ai souligné lors de la
discussion générale de façon annexe je
me réjouis de l'adoption de notre
amendement en séance qui met en place
une prévoyance pour les cas de
multiplicité de contrats chez même mê
prieur notamment les CDD effectué
successivement sans interruption dans
l'entreprise pour autant et c'est là mon
grand regret de ne pas avoir pris le
temps de débattre le texte laisse trop
de doute et interrogation et la
discussion parlementaire si tantit
d'ailleurs qu'on puisse parler de réelle
discussion puisque à partir de cet
après-midi c'était une suite de
monologue et la discussion parlementaire
n'a pas permis d'améliorer un texte qui
en avait bien besoin j'avais choisi en
introduction de nos débats traité de ce
projet de loi sous l'angle de la
démocratie sociale des droits nouveau et
de la sécurisation de
l'emploi en conclusion aujourd'hui je
déplore toujours l'absence d'avancier
significatif sur la mobilité contrainte
comme nous l'avons montré les
licenciement les licenciements massifs
facilités et le changement des clauses
du contraint imposé aux salariés désolé
de vous le dire monsieur le ministre je
le regrette et on aurait pu faire
autrement et sur certains points il y a
une régression des droits des salariés
et plus globalement ce que nous
craignons c'est que la mise en place de
ce régime d'exception pour sauver les
entreprises aujourd'hui seulement
valable pour les graves difficultés
conjoncturelles finissent par se
généraliser à l'ensemble de la société
et à l'ensemble des relations sociale
c'est
pourquoi ce texte laisse encore trop de
doute d'
ogation il n'a pas défini dans le détail
un certain nombre de droits nouveaux et
par ailleurs on aurait pu améliorer ce
ce qui porte atteinte au droits des
salariés c'est donc avec regret que le
groupe écologist s'abstiendra à défaut
d'avoir obtenu un réel débat sur ce
texte et les améliorations que nous
jugions nécessaires et pour finir nous
avons avancé l'idée d'un observatoire
parlementaire de la dém ocratie sociale
suite à ce débat aujourd'hui avorté dans
l'émicycle je pense qu'il est nécessaire
de le mettre en place je vous remercie
merci chers collègues dernière
intervenante en explication de vote sur
le texte Christian desontess
oui madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur madame
la rapporteur mes chers
collègues nous arrivons donc au terme de
l'examen par le Sénat du projet de loi
sur la sécurisation de l'emploi et des
parcours professionnels nous le faisons
dans un contexte de crise économique
particulièrement grave avec un grand
nombre de chôeurs et une montée de la
précarité et nous nous pensons que ce
projet de loi peut apporter un certain
nombre de réponses aux salariés dans les
entreprises je voudrais revenir sur
l'examen de ce texte au Sénat en
commission d'abord et en séance euh
depuis plusieurs jours qui a permis
d'améliorer ce texte de l'enrichir mais
aussi de noter un certain nombre de
points de vigilance sur ce sur ce projet
de loi sur ce qui sera bientôt la loi
sur la
sécurisation point de vigilance qui ont
été rappelés par un certain nombre de
collègues je pense à la question du
temps partiel en particulier dans les
entreprises de service à la personne je
pense aussi au travail des femmes je
pense aussi à la question toujours
récurrente de l'insertion
professionnelle des jeunes parce que
bien évidemment il faut s'occuper des
salariés dans l'entreprise mais il faut
aussi permettre à ceux qui ne sont pas
dans l'entreprise d'y accéder et c'est
un problème extrêmement important pour
pour les jeunes le texte que nous allons
voter euh renforce les droits des
salariés et il leur crée de nouveaux
droits j'en citerai quelquesuns d'autres
l'ont fait avant moi moi la
complémentaire santé avec le débat sur
euh la clause de désignation avec le
renchérissement des contrats précaires
des CDD avec l'encadrement du du temps
partiel avec la
portabilité des droits au chômage le
compte personnel de de formation euh si
quelqu'un peut m'expliquer que ça n'est
pas un renforcement des droits des
salariés dans l'entreprise je suis
intéressée pour qu'on me l'explique ce
texte renforce aussi le dialogue social
cela a été dit il permet aussi en 3è
lieu
l'anticipation des mutations économiques
et la refonde des procédures de
licenciement collectif je veux aussi
rappeler que ce projet de loi est
l'aboutissement d'un équilibre entre un
accord national interprofessionnel qui a
été signé en janvier par un certain
nombre de d'organisations
représentatives trois organisations
d'employeurs de syndicat d'employeurs et
trois organisations de syndicat de
salariés équilibre entre cet accord
national interprofessionnel entre le
projet de loi et le travail du
gouvernement et à ce moment je veux
remercier le gouvernement d'avoir
élaboré ce projet de loi en consultant
l'ensemble des partenaires sociaux et
ceux aussi qui n'avaient pas signé cet
accord national interprofessionnel et
puis bien évidemment équilibre avec le
travail législatif que nous
achevons nous l'avons dit au début de ce
débat dans la discussion générale nous
le redisons aujourd'hui nous le groupe
socialiste dans sa grande majorité nous
avons la conviction j'ai compris qu'elle
n'était pas partagé complètement sur les
bandes de cette assemblée nous avons la
conviction que ce texte marque une
avancée dans les entreprises pour les
salariés bien sûr cela a été dit et et
je le redis ici au gouvernement il
faudra être particulièrement vigilant
pour contrôler l'application de la loi
dans les entreprises mais là aussi nous
faisons confiance aux représentants des
salariés pour des pour les défendre dans
les entreprises dans chacune des
entreprises et c'est en cela aussi que
que ce texte est
novateur je veux pour terminer mon
propos remercier bien évidemment
monsieur le rapporteur notre collègue
Claude jeanerau pour son investissement
dans ce texte pour sa disponibilité sa
pédagogie son attention tout au long de
ces débats que ce soit dans la
commission des affaires sociales et ici
dans l'assemblée dans un contexte
parfois disponible don difficile donc
merci à vous pour conclure Madame la
présidente monsieur le ministre mes
chers collègues ça ne vous surprendra
pas le groupe socialiste dans sa très
grande majorité soutiendra ce texte et
le votera merci chers
collègu monsieur le ministre monsieur le
rapporteur mes chers collègues j'ai été
saisie d'une demande de scrutin public
par les groupes socialistes udi et UC et
CRC sur les articles 5 à 20 modifiés par
les amendements proposés ou acceptés par
le gouvernement et l'ensemble du projet
de loi il va donc être procédé au
scrutin public dans les conditions
fixées par l'article 56 du règlement
ceux qui souhaitent voter pour
remettront un bulletin blanc ceux qui
souhaitent voter contre remettront un
bulletin bleu ceux qui souhaitent
s'abstenir remettront un bulletin rouge
le scrutin sera ouvert dans quelques
instants
le scrutin est
ouvert
ne demande à
voter le scrutin est clos j'invite les
secrétaires à procéder au dépouillement
du
scrutin
voilà
peux
disc
résultat du scrutin numéro 220 sur les
articles 5 à 20 modifié par les
amendements proposés ou acceptés par le
gouvernement et sur l'ensemble du projet
de loi relatif à la sécurisation de
l'emploi nombre de votants
344 nombre de suffrage exprimé
196 pour l'adoption
172 contre 24 le Sénat a donc adopté
l'ensemble du projet de loi relatif à la
sécurisation de
l'emploi
la parole à Monsieur le
Rapporteur permettez-moi simplement
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues de vous
dire quelques mots d'abord pour vous
remercier vous tous et toutes malgré la
difficultés et les aléas que nous avons
pu connaître au long de ces journées
vous remercier pour votre engagement
tout au long de ce débat remercier aussi
ma collègue Christiane de montess
naturellement pour les mots aimables
qu'elle a eu à mon endroit et puis vous
dire mais vous l'aviez compris que dans
ce débat je m'étais attaché avec les
autres rapporteurs Catherine Janisson
gaetangor de vous faire partager nos
convictions quant à l'importance
décisive de ce texte pour la cohésion
sociale dans notre pays je me suis
attaché aussi à développer avec eux
toute la pédagogie nécessaire et je
voulais vous remercier de la qualité
d'attention que vous avez bien voulu
m'accorder je voudrais aussi remercier
Monsieur le Ministre et toute son équipe
pour la qualité du dialogue que nous
avons instauré tout au long de de ces
jours depuis en tout cas le moment où où
nous avons commencé de de préparer ce
travail et je pense à ceux aussi très
nombreux que nous avons reçu tout au
long de ces audition et qui nous ont
apporté leur contribution et qui ont
contribué probablement à forger notre
conviction par rapport à ce à ce texte
et puis je ne terminerai pas mon propos
sans
évoquer le concours des trois
administrateurs qui étaient dévolus à à
mes côtés euh je vois que l'un a rejoint
puisque il était plus spécialisé sur la
couverture santé il n'est pas là ce soir
mais vous lui transmettrez mes
remerciements nous avons je crois
constitué une équipe qui s'est montré je
le crois compétente réactive et
offensive je veux leur leur adresser mes
remerciements vraiment les plus
chaleureux en tout cas à vous tous merci
et nous nous retrouverons je crois que
c'est jeudi pour l'adoption définitive
de ce
texte merci monsieur le rapporteur
monsieur le ministre vous avez la parole
oui merci madame la Présidente l'heure
est tardive mais il est évident que je
souhaiterais dire un petit mot aux uns
et aux autres dans cet
hémicycle merci Monsieur Desessard de de
début jusqu'à la fin animé par votre
belle voix les débats de cette de cette
assemblée monsieur le rapporteur merci
infiniment d'abord pour la manière dont
vous avez sé notre travail j'ai j'ai
pour ma part apprécié avec beaucoup de
de plaisir la compétence la gentillesse
qui est la vôtre la patience la
pédagogie qui est la vôre qui était
utile et qui m'a apporté aussi à
moi-même beaucoup comme vous le faites
par fonction auprès de l'ensemble du
Sénat tous ceux qui ont travailler avec
vous je voudrais madame la Présidente
saluer à la fois votre présidence mais
autour de vous l'ensemble de vos
collaborateurs et tous ceux qui nous
aurons accompagné pendant quelques jours
et quelques nuits dans dans ce travail
un mot pour pour vous autres sénateurs
et sénatrices que vous soyez sur ces
bancs ou que vous soyez sur cela je
voudrais cela bien entendu je voudrais
vous dire que j'ai une conception du
parlementarisme et du bicamérisme qui
est faite profondément de
respect profondément de respect je ne
demande pas que l'inverse soit
automatique chacun fait ses choix mais
moi j'ai un choix qui est celui de
respecter chacun des parlementaires et
chacun de ceux qui s'expriment
je regrette profondément que la manière
dont le débat s'est engagé sur les trois
premiers articles peut-être les quatre
premiers articles n'est pas permis que
nous allions jusqu'au bout avec cette
volonté
d'argumentation d'écoute de réponse et
donc à partir de là de partage d'un
raisonnement ce qui ne veut pas dire un
partage des opinions et un partage au
bout du compte des votes et des
directions entreprise c'est aussi ça la
démocratie je le regrette très
profondément et vous le savez parce que
je ne suis pas de ceux qui au cour de ma
vie parlementaire a
montré une réticence au débat et y
compris à la confrontation c'est ainsi
il fallait que le les décisions prises
par la Conférence des Présidents en
toute connaissance de cause de tous les
parties prenantes et de l'ensemble des
groupes puissent être respecté c'est ce
qui aura été fait mais
sachez que si un texte comme celui-ci
vaut le débat et il a eu
lieu vaut des appréciations certainement
différentes elles sont légitimes il y a
des organisations syndicales qui portent
des appréciations différentes sur ce
texte ce texte est certainement un des
grands moments et sa mise en œuvre est
certainement un des grands moments de
notre droit social de ces dernières
années certains diront un moment
dangereux ils ont parfaitement le droit
de le dire moi je dis un moment de
progrès un moment de perspective un
moment d'ouverture ce sont des
opportunités nouvelle qui s'ouvre
aujourd'hui au dialogue social que ce
soit au niveau national que ce soit dans
les branches que ce soit dans les
entreprises c'est une autre manière
d'apprécier le développement économique
et social celui qui fait des acteurs
dans les entreprises dans les sociétés
des éléments responsables nous voulons
des partenaires responsables pour que
des partenaires soient responsables il
faut qu'ils aient des responsabilités et
c'est ce que vous avez voulu c'est ce
que vous avez décidé et c'est ce qui
permettra à la France de manière plus
forte plus puissante d'aborder et de
surmonter les problèmes profond qu'elle
traverse aujourd'hui merci merci
monsieur le
ministre nous quittons l'hémicycle du
Sénat merci à vous d'avoir suivi cette
séance pour la revoir notre site
internet publicsenat.fr très bonne
journée à
tous